Arnaud Van Rudbec. Bonjour.
Bonjour.
Bonjour monsieur le juge. Bonjour.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ?
Bah écoutez, oui, d'abord je suis un
retraité
fraîchement.
2 ans. Ça fait 2 ans que j'ai pris ma
retraite et que je respire après avoir
travaillé pendant 45 ans comme
essentiellement comme juge d'instruction
et toutes les 20. En 20 30 ans à peu
près, je me suis spécialisé dans les
affaires dites financières.
Que vous étiez juge, vous avez fait
d'énormes dossiers. Hm
hm.
Des dossiers des scandales d'état, des
dossiers bien louches, des dossiers bien
sombres. Qu'est-ce que vous en gardez
après plus de 40 ans de d'activité
professionnelle ? Qu'est-ce qu'il y a en
commun avec tous ces délinquants ?
Ce qu'il y a en commun dans cette dans
cette délinquence financière euh c'est
qu'ils sont euh c'est des gens qui sont
en place. Voilà, la différence de la
petite, j'aime pas ce terme-là, mais de
la délinquence habituelle où là vous
avez des gens qui ont pas d'argent, qui
sont le chômage, qui sont ou qui ont eu
une enfance difficile ou qu'on on a de
tout. Euh là, on a affaire à des gens
d'un certain niveau, entre guillemets en
niveau social bien sûr et de d'un niveau
financier également euh qui présentent
bien, qui ont fait des études, qui
raisonnent bien. Donc c'est une
délinquence qui est qui est comment dire
euh qui va répondre avec finesse. Euh
j'ai eu affaire à des gens beaucoup plus
intelligents que moi. Vous me direz,
c'est pas difficile. Bon non, riez pas,
c'est c'est une réalité.
Donc c'est ça a été tout un je pas dire
un jeu mais un exercice euh qui m'a
passionné parce que
quand on joue, c'est un peu comme quand
je joue aux échecs, on aime pas perdre,
on aime bien gagner et euh découvrir la
vérité puisque c'était ça mon objectif
avec des gens évidemment qui rarement
racontaient ce qu'ils avaient fait.
Quand on se retrouve dans votre bureau
avec quelqu'un qui vous savez que c'est
un grand mythomane
et vous avez suffisamment de biscuits
pour savoir que c'est un grand mythomane
et il continue de vous de vous myonner
en face de vous les yeux dans les yeux.
Qu'est-ce que ça fait ? Qu'est-ce qui
passe dans votre tête qu'en face de vous
ça pipote et ça joue de la flû avec
cette douce mélopée ? qui en général
surtout euh [grognement] euh bien
ponctué chez celle de nos politiques.
Ouais. Quand quelqu'un est mythomane euh
on se'en rend pas toujours compte au
départ. Euh souvent euh les mythomanes,
les escrocs, je vais le faire d'escroc,
euh c'est pas écrit dessus, voyez. Et
ils ont un pouvoir de conviction
voir de séduction.
euh qui fait que si vous n'avez pas la
garde proche, euh ils vont vous
embarquer, ils vont vous entraîner sur
des fausses
des des chemins qui sont faux, voilà,
qui sont qui correspondent pas à la
réalité. Euh donc, faut leur résister
dans un premier temps,
pour leur résister tout en les écoutant
parce que le métier du juge, c'est
d'abord d'écouter les gens. Il y a
toujours une part une part de vrai chez
chez chaque personne, même quand elle
manque, il y a quelque chose de vrai.
Donc il faut avoir un peu de recul,
enfin suffisamment de recul pour pour
décrypter. Euh le problème c'est que
quand on a décrypté, quand on situe la
personne qu'on quand on a compris
qu'elle vous emmené, qu'elle vous menait
en bateau parce que les faits sont là,
parce que vous avez des éléments, euh
les termes de l'échange sont pas les
mêmes. C'està-dire qu'à ce moment-là, le
juge peut tendre des per laisser aller
tout en sachant très bien, en ayant
compris ce qu'il faisait et pourquoi il
le faisait. La difficulté, c'est avant.
C'est avant parce que
là on peut être pris sur des on peut on
peut le suivre parce que ces personnes
qui sont supérieurement intelligentes,
les les escrocs sont supérieurement
intelligents et ils vont lire dans vos
pensées quelque part. Ils vont ils vont
s'imprégner de vous, ils vont vous
manipuler, ils savent ce que vous savez
et en fonction de ce qu'il savent de de
ce savoir, ils savent aussi ce que vous
ne savez pas. Donc ils vont vous
embarquer, ils vont partir sur du vrai
et ils vont rajouter du vrai semblable.
Et c'est difficile
d'y résister, sauf à prendre son temps,
à réfléchir, à confronter avec les
éléments du dossier parce qu'on
travaille sur des sur des dossiers et on
s'en aperçoit pas tout de suite.
Quand vous en apercevez, ça fait quoi ?
On a la clé.
Euh si j'ai une personne qui est dans
une affaire avec d'autres et que c'est
elle qui ment parce que souvent on a des
versions antagonistes et on sait pas qui
ment et qui dit la vérité. Euh quand on
a compris ça, on a on a la clé du
dossier. Donc à partir de ce moment-là,
on peut bâtir le dossier et le pousser
dans ses contradictions. Il faut savoir
où ça se trouve. Voilà. Mais quand on a
trouvé cette clé, vous savez, bâtir un
dossier, c'est compliqué. C'est des
affaires qui sont qui sont très
compliquées avec des comptes offshore,
avec des masques, des hommes de paille,
des trust, des sociétés panaméennes,
tout ce que vous voudrez, des comptes au
Liban, à Singapour, aujourd'hui à Dubaï
qui est devenu la reine des places
financières. C'est un vrai scandale.
Dubaï vo les les Émirats arabes unis
enfin particulièrement Dubaï donc il n'y
a que des masques. Le juge il voit que
des masques au départ et souvent quand
il quand on lui ouvre le dossier, c'est
parce que justement personne n'y
comprend rien et il doit à partir de ce
moment-là comment dire pour avancer il
faut qu'il ait une stratégie d'enquête.
Pour la déterminer, il faut qu'il ait
des intuitions.
Mais il y a rien de plus dangereux que
l'intuition
parce queil y a des intuitions qui sont
bonnes, mais il y a aussi des intuitions
qui sont mauvaises. Donc à partir des
hypothèses qu'il va formuler, des
intuitions qu'il peut avoir, il a des
pouvoirs pour faire des vérifications
qui vont prendre du temps parce que plus
le dossier est compliqué, plus ça va
prendre de temps si on fait le travail
sérieusement.
Donc c'est c'est ça l'exercice qui
consiste à petit à petit à avancer et
alors on avance par strat, c'est-à-dire
que on est dans le brouillard, on va
chercher puis tout d'un coup tac, il y a
quelque chose qui qui apparaît. Ah bah
oui, j'avais pas compris ça mais c'est
tellement évident. Je vais reprendre. Ah
bah oui, voilà. Donc et une fois qu'on a
une clé, on va progresser jusqu'à ce
qu'on ait il y a plusieurs étapes à
franchir avant d'y arriver. On n'y
arrive pas toujours. On y arrive pas
toujours parce que euh les les je pense
qu'on va en parler mais les les paradis
fiscaux par définition sont pas
seulement des paradis fiscaux, c'est
aussi des paradis judiciaires, hein.
C'estàd c'est un certain pays où où le
juge n'a pas accès ou faiblement accès
aux informations. Donc s'il a pas accès
au flux, parce que c'est ça qui compte,
il pourra pas bâtir un dossier. il
pourra pas renvoyer les personnes devant
un tribunal s'il a pas les preuves.
Je vais je vais vous poser une question
avant de de délayer l'écume des choses.
H
h
est-ce que les États occidentaux et pas
occidentaux ont besoin des paradis
fiscaux pour survivre ? Est-ce que les
partis politiques occidentaux
ont besoin des paradis fiscaux, des
caisses noires, des dark pool, des tous
ces montages [soupir]
pour
résister, vivre et si on leur surprime,
si on leur supprime les paradis fiscaux,
les montages douteux, les financements
douteux, ainsi de suite, il
s'effondrerait comme un château de
cartes.
Alors là, il y a deux questions. Les
États ou les partis politiques ? Je
commencer par les politiques. Parti
politique, c'est le plus simple. Il y a
eu une période
c'est pas toujours le cas.
J'ose espérer. Je ne pense pas.
Comment il s'appelit le le le mec de
droite qui s'était fait serrer sur le
quai de la guerre avec des mallettes de
billet en partance pour la Belgique là.
Vous qui s'amusait à poster des photos
où il était à de minu ? Il était dans le
gouvernement ambassadeur le gars. Je
crois bien non. La communauté va nous
retrouver son petit nom.
Ouais. Ouais. Vous savez, j'ai à force
d'avoir fréquenté des amnésiesques, je
le deviens moi-même. [rires]
J'ai pas connu cette personne en tout
cas. Euh non, les j'ai connu euh
l'époque dans les années 90 où il n'y
avait pas de financement public et où
les partis politiques, un certain nombre
d'entre eux euh se finançaient par euh
bah par des intermédiaires qui leur
reversaient de l'argent et qui
l'encaissaient dans les paradis fiscaux.
Euh il y a des valises de billets, la
Suisse a joué un rôle important par
exemple. Euh il y a eu cette époque et
je dirais que dans les années 90,
on est un certain nombre de juges à à
avoir quand même mis notre nez dans ces
affaires-là. Et pas qu'en France
d'ailleurs, euh en Espagne, en Italie,
l'opération manipulité
euh c'était les les exemples les plus
les plus les plus frappants et en
quelque sorte on a mis fin à une
certaine impunité. Je dis pas qu'on a
réussi à identifier tout le monde, loin
de là, mais on a modifié, on a contribué
à la modification de la donne. C'estàd
que les politiques ont eu peur à partir
de ce moment-là puisque la justice
commençait à instruire ces dossiers de
financement politique qui ne l'étaient
pas jusque-là. He c'est ça la
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi ils étaient pas ?
C'était parce qu'il y avait le procureur
qui tournait la tête parce que les
dossiers déjà les procureurs, il y a un
certain nombre de procureur qui
étouffait les affaires.
Comment ? en ne saisant pas les juges
d'instruction.
Faut savoir que quand un juge
d'instruction est saisi d'une affaire A,
il découvre une affaire B en cherchant.
Il pas il peut pas instruire l'affaire
B. Il est obligé de demander
l'autorisation du procureur. Moi, j'ai
connu des cas où où le parquet refusait
de me saisir et j'ai pas pu instruire
les affaires B. Donc, j'ai vu des
affaires m'échapper.
C'est c'était ça le fonctionnement. Et
ce ce que ce que j'ai voulu euh parce
que j'ai écrit un livre là récemment
puisque j'ai témoigné sur sur toute
cette époque, j'ai voulu montrer la
révolution qui s'était commis qui qui
qui s'était faite. Il y a une évolution
considérable dans les relations entre la
justice et le pouvoir politique à
travers ces affairesl. C'estàd que moi
quand j'arrive dans la magistrature, je
suis tout jeune et cetera, j'ai
dans 7 ans, c'est ça ? Oui, j'ai mes
idéaux, je vais être confronté à une
première affaire euh alors avec
l'affaire Boulin que que tout le monde
connaît aujourd'hui, une histoire de
vente de terrain avec un ministre et
cetera euh qui fait va faire l'objet euh
de d'investigation et qui va se
suicider. Euh et bien lorsque je suis
confronté à cette affaire, cette
première affaire à l'époque, mais jamais
il y a une affaire de financement
politique qui ne sort. Jamais.
On remonte pas. Les juges ne vont pas
dans sur ce terrainlà. Et d'ailleurs, ce
qui est paraît anormal, c'est que des
juges y aillent. Alors, j'ai j'en ai
fait les frais. L'affaire Boulin, il a
écrit une lettre très très m'accusant,
très accusatrice à mon égard. pas quand
même mon égard d'ailleurs. Après, j'ai
été confronté au financement du Parti
socialiste, l'affaire urbain, j'ai eu le
droit à tout un congrès du Parti
socialiste. C'était plus l'affaire Henry
Emmanueli, trésorier du Parti socialiste
que je m'apprêtais à mettre en examen ou
inculper à l'époque. C'est mon c'est
l'affaire Van Winbec devant tout un
congrès du parti politique. Donc,
j'arrive à une époque où ce qui se
paraît tout à fait anormal, c'est que
les juges aillent enquêter sur ces
affairesl. J'ai pour la première fois,
j'ai perquisitionné un parti politique,
le parti socialiste en plus parti au
pouvoir. François Mitteran, président de
la République, qui va se permettre de
dire le 14 juillet euh c'est une
procédure assez bizarre
dans laquelle est impliqué l'un de ses
amis. Il est président de la République
en en exercice. Ça n'effrait personne.
Vous imaginez le chemin qui a été
parcouru depuis ? Alors, j'ai j'ai
également mon collègue le juge Alphè qui
lui s'est retrouvé
face au financement du parti de Jacques
Chirac avec la la mairie de Paris et
cetera. Lui, on lui a attendu des
pièges.
Ressemble à quoi ?
Une mallette remis remise par son
beau-père euh à un intermédiaire pour
essayer ou c'était le contraire. C'était
de l'argent qui était remis à son
beau-père, du liquide avec la police qui
va intervenir comme par hasard à chaud.
Je crois que le ministre de l'intérieur
était un certain Charles Pasquis à
l'époque. Tout ça pour jeter le
discrédit sur le juge.
Donc c'est pour vous dire que regardez
le chemin aujourd'hui. Aujourd'hui les
les partis politiques ne sont plus
au-dessus des lois.
Je regarde le chemin.
Oui, [raclement de gorge]
je vois que le coffre de Benalain, on
l'a jamais retrouvé.
Je vois que
[raclement de gorge] on met du temps
pour faire certaines perquisitions
puis quand on arrive, il y a plus rien.
Je vois que il y a pas trop d'hommes
politiques
en prison.
Ils sont en aménagement de peine en
général. Ils prennent toujours moins de
2 ans. Donc ça ça s'aménage plus
facilement avec un petit bracelet
électronique et puis une petite maison
en Corse.
Moi, je les vois pas trop ramasser le
savon dans les douches Fleur Mirogis.
Je vois pas souvent en fait de vraies
peine du truc quand il ressort. Par
exemple, imaginez-vous un homme
politique, on voit sortir de prison, il
est tatoué.
On en voit pas trop souvent. comme ça,
on les voit, hop et puis ils attendent
un peu les leur temps d'inibilité et
puis après hop, on les revoit euh
sur le trottoir.
Comment ça se fait ça ? C'est un peu
comme les Roumains, les les roumains
mineurs.
Hop, on les attrape tout de suite ils
sont dans la rue.
Est-ce que politique c'est un peu comme
des roumins mineurs ? Ils sont ils sont
jamais responsables.
On
n jamais responsable de ce qu'on a pas
fait.
Mais par contre, on doit être
responsable de ce qu'on a fait, c'est
clair. Mais dans votre question, moi
j'assume la partie instruction,
les investigations. Je peux vous
garantir qu'à ce niveau-là, il y a pas
de privilège. Voilà, moi j'ai j'ai fait
ça. Après, quand un dossier est terminé,
je le renvoie devant le tribunal. Le
tribunal met les peines qu'il estime
devoir mettre.
Voyez, c'est plus le travail du juge
d'instruction, c'est le travail des
juges. Et après l'application de la
peine, est-ce qu'on le met en prison ?
Est-ce qu'on lui met le bracelet
électronique ? C'est juste pas mon
problème.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous ?
Vous savez, moi aussi je suis
responsable. Je suis responsable de
rien. Moi, ma responsabilité,
c'est d'aller enquêter
sur les vrais responsable où qu'il soit,
tel que je peux les concevoir
rationnellement et si ça tient de les
renvoyer devant une juridiction
avec la crainte évidemment que j'ai pas
tout vérifié, qu'il y ait des il faut
pas que je laisse des portes ouvertes
parce que on ferme les porte de mettre
un innocent en prison.
Non.
Oui, enfin ça en tout cas c'est pas moi
qui le mets en prison, c'est c'est
d'autres qui vont apprécier. Mais si mon
dossier est mal ficelé, la personne sera
relaxée par le tribunal, c'est normal.
Donc il y a deux il y a deux choses
qu'il faut bien comprendre. Il y a les
enquêtes, les investigations et je peux
vous dire que là il y a des privilèges
pour personne.
Voilà, c'est là la révolution qui s'est
produite.
Après les tribunaux, bah ils prononcent
les sanctions qu'ils estiment devoir
prononcé. Qu'est-ce que
après c'est le citoyen qui se fait son
idée, il trouve que c'est c'est grave,
c'est pas grave, c'est voilà, c'est
c'est pas ma responsabilité. Vous voyez
ce que je veux dire ? Moi, je peux vous
garantir que si vous me donnez un
dossier et j'en ai eu,
j'ai tout j'ai tout fouillé et je suis
allé également sur les vrais
responsables dans la première affaire
que je vous citais tout à tout à
l'heure, l'affaire Boulin, c'est c'est
un ministre qui a 11 ans de longévité,
j'ai été chercher ses comptes, ce qui ne
se faisait pas à l'époque. Et donc
l'acte anormal,
c'était pas l'acte du ministre, c'est ça
devenait le mien. C'està-dire vous
rendez compte des juges qui volent comme
ça qui qui parce que les politiques
considéraent qu'il n'avaient pas de
compte à rendre. Donc ce qui était
anormal, c'est qu'un juge aille fouiller
des comptes, remonte dans ces enquêtes
là. C'est là que le balancier euh a
changé. Alors après la peine.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous en
tant que citoyen
participant à la vie de la cité ?
magistrat juge, qu'est-ce que vous
pensez des
Je suis euh
je peux je peux pas porte je peux pas
critiquer euh porter un jugement parce
que c'est pas en tant que citoyen que
vous me faites venir aujourd'hui. Donc
je je veux pas critiquer euh des
décisions de justice.
C'est pas c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
le c'est pas opportun. Enfin je peux pas
le faire. Vous comprenez comprenez ma
position. Euh je suis pas là, je suis
pas là pour régler des comptes. Je suis
pas là pour euh
voilà. Euh après, j'ai mon opinion. Bien
sûr que j'ai mon opinion. Euh
votre opinion c'est laquelle ?
Mais mon opinion, je peux pas vous la
livrer parce que c'est une opinion qui
est qui est personnelle. Et puis je vais
vous dire, moi ce n'est plus mon sujet.
Euh mon sujet, c'est d'instruire. C'est
c'est ça mon métier. C'est voir qui fait
quoi et renvoyer les vrais responsables.
Après, c'est un autre sujet. Voilà. J'ai
pas m'exprimer sur la sur la décision de
justice.
Je ferai pas. Bah oui, c'est normal mais
je vous comprenez que je ne puisse pas
le faire.
Accepter.
Si j'étais simple citoyen, si j'avais
pas été juste, je vous dirai ce que je
pense. Bien sûr,
il y en a des trucs à dire. Non,
mais il y a toujours, vous savez, alors
les décisions de justice euh
dans quel qu'elles soit, elles sont
forcément critiquées
au moins par une partie des personnes.
Est-ce que Est-ce que les tribunaux se
rendent compte qu'ils sont en train
d'affaiblir la confiance des Français
dans leur justice ?
Moi, je pense que les tribunaux, ils
prononcent les peines qu'ils estiment
devoir prononcer. Ils sont libres à ce
niveau-là.
Alors
et si s'il considère que tel fait est
moins grave qu'un autre, que la personne
a un travail que c que ça et cetera
après il y a plein de considérations. On
peut pas généraliser de toute façon faut
prendre les cas les cas séparément.
Pourquoi c'est grave de taper dans
l'argent public ?
Ah c'est évident. Je veux dire que
l'argent public, bah l'argent public
être évident pour tout le monde. Non,
mais il y a toujours des des des
personnes qui qui détournent des fonds
ou qui trahissent la confiance qu'on met
en eux. Le problème de l'argent public,
c'est qu'on vous fait confiance. On vous
élu pour ça. On vous éluie pour ça. Donc
si vous détournez de l'argent, ça pose
un problème. Donc qu'ils aient, mais
vous savez, ça pas été facile de passer
cette étape, de faire en sorte qu'ils
aient des comptes à rendre.
C'est ça qui est important. déjà au
premier au premier chef,
c'est pas c'est pas un peu petit bras,
c'estd que là, ils ont des comptes à
rendre mais il ils ont des peines petits
bras. Du moi, je trouve personnellement
avec mon ma propre opinion qui n'est pas
l'opinion d'un juge, je trouve que taper
10 15 millions d'argent public, faire
des procédures qui nous coûtent un bras
citoyen des années, des décennies et
ensuite il se retrouve avec 2 ans
aménageable avec un bracelet
électronique
et et une amende peanuts
mais c'est je peux d'autant m'exprimer
que j'ai instruit moi-même à ces
d'affaires dont on parle aujourd'hui.
Donc je revenons à ma première question.
Est-ce que les États ont besoin des
droit au silence ? J'invoque le droit au
silence.
Est-ce que j'ai le droit de vous
torturer ?
Ah attention, la Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme existe et je suis
un farvant fervant pertisant de la
Convention européenne des droits de
l'homme.
Nous sommes dans un pays où on n pas
signé cette convention. Est-ce que la
torture vous ?
Si si.
Ah bon ? On n pas en Arabie Saoudite
aujourd'hui ?
Non. [rires]
Est-ce que la torture vous pose problème
?
La torture ? Oui, bien sûr.
Pourquoi ?
Bah, c'est inacceptable la torture.
Bah, enfin, c'est évident.
C'est dans un état droit, on ne torture
pas.
Non, ça ça pour moi c'est une évidence.
Les États-Unis qui torturent.
Ah bah ça, parler de Guantalamo. Ah oui,
bien sûr.
Oui. Mais attendez, c'est pas
défendable.
C'est pas défendable.
Revenons, revenons à ma première
question. Est-ce que les États ont
besoin des paradis fiscaux pour
fonctionner ? Est-ce que
J'ai l'impression que chaque état a son
petit paradis planqué à gauche ou à
droite ?
Oui, tous les pays. Bah, regardez la
France.
La France
historiquement,
la Suisse
à l'est, faites le Tour de France,
le Luxembourg,
vous descendez sur les côtes, vous avez
Gersz, GZ et cetera. Euh vous descendez
plus au sud, bah il y avait Andor. Bon,
enor c'est un peu faibli. Bon, vous
alliez jusqu'à Monaco
euh et puis j'ai oublié Lenstein, c'est
un peu plus loin. Donc je veux dire que
les Badlines, ils existaient tout autour
de la France. Donc ça me paraît évident.
Alors les États, ceux qui dirigent
les élites, les élites politiques, les
élites économiques ont eu recours
évidemment à ces pays pour bah pour
échapper à l'impôt, pour détourner des
fonds, pour corrompre et cetera
évidemment ou les entreprises également.
Qu'est-ce que ça vous fait vous en tant
que juge d'avoir des biscuits menant
vers une affaire et qu'on vous objecte
le le secret défense ? Ça vous met un
mur, ça vous dit tiens ce qui n'est pas
dit et dit avec cette ce secret. Je me
suis heurté Je me suis heurté au secret
défense dans des affaires importantes
euh dans l'affaire
et surtout dans l'affaire des frégades
de Taïwan que je n'ai pas pu instruire.
En tout cas, l'affaire des frégades de
Taïwan, j'ai pas trouvé la clé du
problème. Euh, j'ai pas pu faire des
auditions des dirigeants, ils avaient
interdiction de parler. J'ai pas j'ai pu
saisir aucun document. Ils étaient
classifiés secret défense
et euh le le juge n'a pas ne sait pas
pourquoi.
Je sais pas pourquoi. C'est le ministre
qui décide de lui opposer. Bon, c'est
lui qui classifie. Ensuite, il y a une
commission qui se réunit. Mais la
commission dit oui ou non. Mais elle ne
donne aucune explication. Donc le juge
ne sait pas. Et d'ailleurs, on m'a
reproché dans le dans c'est dans le
dossier des frégates de Tagwan d'avoir
d'avoir réitéré ma demande quatre ou
cinq fois. Voilà. Oui,
quand j'avais un pouvoir de droite, je
me disais bon, j'essaie. Quand je vois
un pouvoir de gauche arriver, je me
disais peut-être que là ça va. Bah non,
non, ça passait pas. Donc ce que je n'ai
pas compris, si vous voulez, c'est que
mes demandes ne portaient pas sur des
sur le code nucléaire pour le bouton,
pour le tout ce qu'on voudra et cetera.
sur des questions d'armement, pas du
tout dans des un dossier de de vente
d'armes. Je voulais simplement savoir où
étaient parties les commissions et ce
qui avait été déclaré par ces
entreprises au titre de ces commissions
puisque ces commissions elles étaient
validées, déclaré validées par Bercy et
défiscalisé.
En conséquence et bien ces déclarations,
j'avais pas accès
et là où je je pense que cette
législation est contraire en elle est
contraire, elle va à l'encontre
s'agissant, je parle des commissions,
elle va à l'encontre des engagements de
la France
qui a fini par signer tardivement en
2000,
la convention de l'OCDE.
réprimant la corruption d'agent public
étrangers. Faut savoir que jusqu'en
2000, c'est pas une infraction en
France. C'est qu'une entreprise pouvait
arroser un ministre du pétrole de je ne
sais quel pays, lui virer de l'argent
sur des comptes suisses, c'était pas une
infraction.
Donc c'était défiscalisé,
validé par Bercy et pas une infraction.
Donc les juges ne pouvaient rien faire.
Il a fallu une convention internationale
pour l'imposer à la France.
Oui. Donc pour moi, lorsqu'on oppose le
secret défense dans des affaires de
commission, on ne respecte pas ses
propres engagements de lutter contre la
contre la corruption dans la mesure où
qu'est-ce qu'on protège ?
Qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu'on peut
protéger quand on oppose à un juge le
secret défense qui enquête sur des des
des commissions internationales versées
? à des intermédiaires dans des marchés
de vente d'armes. Vous az bien posé la
question
évidemment.
Alors
bah qu'est-ce qu'on peut protéger ?
Le secret des affaires mais pour les
militaires.
Oui mais on protège quoi ? On protège
les bénéficiaires des commissions
ou on protège
la destination des commissions ?
Exactement. Ou sinon on peut aussi
protéger les intermédiaires.
Alors Oui. Et pourquoi on les protège
les intermédiaires ? C'est la question
que je vous pose.
Ah oui, bah c'est pas moi qu'il faut la
poser. Mais si ces intermédiaires
perçoivent des commissions exorbitante.
C'est quoi exorbitante ?
20 % du contrat.
Parlez pour Taiwan là.
Oui. 500
contrat 2 milliards et demi, il y a 500
millions qui
il y a 500. Voilà. Exactement. des
contrats de 2 milliards et demi à 500
millions de commissions qui sont
acceptés par le prix global est accepté
par l'acheteur. Bah,
il faut bien financer aussi ces petits
partis politiques.
Ah, donc ça s'appelle quoi ça ? Ça si
tel est le cas, ça s'appelle quelque
chose de bon procédé.
Voilà. Alors, je parle je parlerai pas
de ce cas-là parce que je veux pas
je veux pas citer de cas précis. Ça
s'est terminé par un non lieu puisqu'on
a jamais rien su grâce au secret
défense. Mais bon, on peut penser que
lorsqu'une commission est est importante
et versé dans un contrat d'armement,
qu'elle est acceptée par le pays
acheteur, on peut penser qu'il y a de la
corruption du côté du pays acheteur.
Bon, en parallèle, donc on dit circuler,
rien à voir, secret défense, mais en
parallèle, on a signé, la France a signé
une convention
selon laquelle il fallait lutter contre
la corruption des agents étrangers.
Alors, je vais vous dire le le motif
motif. Ah oui, mais attendez, si vous
sanctionnez l'entreprise française,
c'est une autre entreprise allemande,
américaine ou japonaise qui va prendre
le marché. Ah oui, mais à ce moment-là,
on fait plus rien à ce moment-là et on
continue à entretenir une corruption.
Alors, c'est particulièrement vrai dans
les pays africains
où vous avez un certain nombre de
dictateurs
qui qui corrompu
qui se constituent des avoirs
considérables
en Suisse, à Singapour, à Dubaï,
en France
ou ailleurs qui vont investir dans des
appartements à Paris, l'affaire des
biens des biens malakis. Bon, et en même
temps, un pays où les gens sont les plus
pauvres.
Et on valide ça.
C'est pas nous,
c'est le pouvoir.
Bah les États, vous m'avez dit les États
et tout ça avec des entreprises
occidentales.
Donc donc c'est un système qui est en
place.
On affirme qu'on va lutter. Mais
regardez, écoutez, regardez quand un
certain nombre de de ces chefs d'état
sont tombés, c'est là qu'on s'aperçoit
que
Benali en Tunisie, il est à peine tombé,
on apprend que il aurait détourné des
sommes considérables.
Des kilos d'or.
Comment ?
Des kilos. Voilà. Prenez al on peut
prendre les l'exemple de l'Algérie,
l'exemple de l'Égypte avec Mubarak et
cetera. Bon, ça veut dire que tant que
ces dictateurs sont en place,
nos problèmes, on leur sort le tapis
rouge et c'est quand il tombe que là on
peut et là on s'étonne ou là là
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Mais vous
pensez que depuis qu'il y a eu ces
affaires-là, la communauté
internationale aurait pu réagir en
disant "Bon, on peut pas faire toujours
faire comme si on savait pas, on sait.
On sait mais on tolère. Voilà. Et c'est
à ce niveau-là. Il n'y a pas C'est ce
que j'ai voulu dénoncer moi dans mon
dans mon livre parce que pendant 20 ans,
j'ai exploré ces circuits. D'abord, j'ai
voulu expliquer aux gens comment ils
fonctionnaient ces circuits. J'ai mis le
temps à comprendre. Alors
intelligence moyenne mais grosse masse
de travail pour arriver à comprendre à
peu près comment ça marche.
Comme tous les gens moyens d'ailleurs.
Comme tous les gens moyens. Et je suis
je suis un peu anxieux parce que je je
réponds à à quelqu'un qui qui est d'une
intelligence supérieure à la mienne.
Marqué
ça me paraît tellement évident et je
pense que ceux qui nous écoutent en sont
convaincus. Bonz fait perdre le fil de
mes idées. Qu'est-ce que je disais ?
Oui, l'intelligence moyenne c'est quoi ?
C'est oui, c'est comprendre. Voilà,
c'est comprendre comment voilà, j'ai
j'ai mis des années, j'ai fini par
comprendre et je dis je vais expliquer
comment ça marche les trusts, les
comptes à à Singapour, à Dubaï, les
montages, comment comment ça existe,
pourquoi c'est toléré et cetera pour
pour montrer aux citoyens lambda que
nous sommes.
Là, il y a il y a des états,
il y a des impôts, il y a il y a des
dépenses, c'est les hôpitaux, il y a des
écoles et cetera. Bon, il y a les
déficits et de l'autre côté, il y a une
masse d'argent considérable cachée
dans ces paradis fiscaux et on fait
rien.
Alors, on fait rien. Il y a des
conventions internationales sur le
blanchiment et l'OCDE après des
initiatives, mais il y a jamais autant
d'argent. Alors, il y a un problème
comment on appelle ça nous ?
Comment
je vais je vais être vulgaire ? Est-ce
que vous m'autorisez d'être vulgaire ?
Je sais que vous avez eu des gens très
vulgaires dans votre bureau,
mais non, j'avais des gens très bien.
Est-ce que c'est pas un petit peu de la
branlette et du soufflage de flû de
faire des petites conventions pour les
journalistes ? On se drape dans les
temps d'art de la vertu et [grognement]
derrière business as usual. Est-ce que
c'est pas ça en fait ? C'est c'estd que
c'est une c'est un grand théâtre
où il faut toujours maintenir la musique
et dès que la musique ralentit un peu,
c'est un peu comme la mer se recule.
C'estàd quand l'économie ralentit,
on voit qui est-ce qui est en short et
qui est-ce qui est à poil.
H
ça c'est vu au Brésil. ralentissement de
la l'activité économique. On a vu tous
les corrompus commencer à s'exciter
parce queils pouvaient pas continuer de
graisser la patte de leur réseau de
corrompu.
Est-ce que là à l'heure actuelle on va
traverser une crise financière
dramatique pour les pays de l'OCDE ? On
va voir les phénomènes de corruption
débarquer un petit peu comme les étoiles
de mer mortes quand la mer se recule se
se retire. Difficile
de prévoir ce qui va se passer, mais je
pense que dans notre monde, ça pourra
pas durer éternellement comme ça.
C'estàd qu'on peut pas vivre dans une
telle hypocrisie.
Alors, vous avez vu qu'il y a eu un
premier pas avec Joe Biden. Là, on n'est
pas sur la fraude fiscale, on n'est pas
sur la corruption et cetera, je suis
d'accord. Mais les outils sont les
mêmes, les paradis fiscaux.
Vous parlez des 12 des 12.5 de taxe
mondiale.
15, pardon. Oui, 15.
15.
On peut penser que c'est insuffisant
mais c'est un premier pas. C'est que là
pour la première fois on va
diminuer si vous voulez l'ampleur des
dégâts quelque part. Pour
pour nos auditeurs, on parle de 15 % de
taxe sur les sociétés à l'échelle
mondiale.
Oui.
Pour éviter en fait de jouer à
J'exfiltre mon pognon un coup au-delà.
parce que les multinationales notamment
les ils sont sur plusieurs états même
sur toute la planète donc ils peuvent
faire remonter les bénéfices dans l'état
où on paye le moins d'impôts. C'est
facile.
Pourquoi est-ce qu'ils ont des filiales
certains ont des filiales aux îles
caillem dans les îles anglo-normandes et
cetera alors qu'ils ont des activités
dans les États où on paye des impôts.
Bon ce qui fait qu'il y a il y a une
distorsion puisque c'est des gafas
payent pas ou très peu d'impôts. Ils
font de l'optimisation fiscale mais ils
utilisent les paradis fiscaux ce qui ce
qui crée une concurrence déloyale avec
ceux qui eux travaillent à l'intérieur
des frontière et qui eux payent leurs
impôts. Bon donc on commence pour la
première fois et je trouve c'est un pas
qui est qui est considérable à dire
taxation minimum 15 % ou qu'on soit même
si on est à l'île de man bah on perra 15
%. Donc c'est déjà un progrès. On peut
penser que c'est pas suffisant. Certains
disent 20 25 30 % mais une fois qu'on
qu'on crée l'outil après on peut on
pourra moduler. Donc vous voyez c'est
très long, c'est beaucoup trop long mais
ça rapportera pas autant que ce que ça
devrait rapporter parce que on est on
sera encore loin de l'égalité mais il y
a un premier pas. Voyez donc c'est un
peu la je dirais la politique des petits
pas mais il y a quand même petits bras
pardon je
des petits pas des petits pas. Je me
serais pas permis de dire les petits
bras, mais vous savez, on joue petits
bras quelquefois
en tout cas des petits pas. Euh c'est un
c'est un bon point mais largement
insuffisant. Euh là, on parle de de
l'optimisation fiscale.
Il y a aussi la fraude fiscale, c'est
encore autre chose. C'est des gens qui
eux détourne de l'argent et qui payent
pas d'impôt. Mais ces outils, ces
paradis fiscaux, ces sociétés offshore,
ces trust, c'est fait pour frauder.
Non,
c'est fait pour optimiser.
Oui, optimiser. Mais j'ai souvent j'ai
j'ai eu une fois une discussion avec un
un avocat américain
? Je donne jamais mes sources.
Cet avocat américain comprend pas euh
parce que son client a acheté une
propriété dans le sud de la France avec
une fondation du Lenstein.
Combien la propriété ? Oh, quelques
millions hein. Euh, toute façon, en
dessous du million d'euros, c'est pas la
peine d'aller au Lenstein, hein. Bon,
donc euh quelqu ceux qui ont la
l'argent, c'est des millions, des
dizaines de millions, voir des
centaines, hein. Bon, donc
il il traverse, il prend l'avion, il
vient me voir, il me dit "Je comprends
pas
pourquoi vous poursuivez mon client."
Bah je lui dis euh écoutez déjà s'il a
si s'il achète par une société au
Leninstein fondation du Linstein qu'il y
a de sa part une volonté d'opacité.
Il me dit non il a le droit il peut le
faire et cetera.
Je dit écoutez à cours d'argument parce
que j'arrivais pas à le convaincre il
finit par finit par me faire douter
parce qu'il dit mais il a le droit.
Je dis oui mais attendez monsieur c'est
très simple moi je vais vous dire les
choses.
Si moi j'achète une maison dans le midi,
je l'achète à mon nom. Pourquoi il y a
des gens qui l'achètent avec une une
fondation de Ltenstein ? Expliquez-moi.
Voyez dialogue de sour qu'on pouvait
qu'on pouvait avoir. Alors derrière
pourquoi il y a une fondation
Lichtenstein ? parce qu'on a des
millions d'euros qu'on veut pas
déclarer. Alors ça peut être de la
fraude fiscale mais ça peut aussi être
de l'argent détourné des entreprises de
la drogue
ou de la drogue. Les mafias aussi hein
qui qui ont qui ont compris que c'était
tu es quand même plus intelligent
d'avoir des comptes cachés que de
tramaler des des valises de billets.
Surtout que là il y a des zéos
supplémentaires à la clé. Donc il y a
tout un monde opaque qui existe et qu'on
accepte qu'on tolère. Voilà quand je dis
ça, je parle de des grandes démocraties.
Il y a à ce niveau-là un défaut. Il n'y
a pas de volonté politique
internationale. Il y a une volonté
politique dans les États. Très bien.
Mais dans les États, on contrôle, on
prévient, on vous colle tous les
contrôles possibles imaginables, on en
rajoute. Voilà. Mais le problème, il est
pas là. Enfin, il est peut-être là, mais
le vrai problème, il est au-delà de nos
frontières, là où il y a tous les
masques, voilà. et et qui sont
parfaitement légaux comme le disait mon
mon avocat américain puisque ces
circuits opaques, ils sont utilisé par
des gens comme les Google andco qui font
de l'opacité de l'optimisation fiscale
mais ils sont aussi utilisés par par les
fraudeurs et par les corrompus tout ce
que vous voudrez.
Quand vous avez cette upper class dans
votre bureau, quand vous avez le
tractivité
de tous les jours de cette upper class,
vous avez en face de vous des gens qui
palpent des centaines de millions
d'euros. Quand vous allez chez eux faire
des perquisitions, il y a des chevaux
tangent à plusieurs millions d'euros
comme babiolle devant la télé.
Vous vous gagnez combien ? Vous gagnez
combien en tant que juge d'instruction ?
Moi, je gagnais 5000 € 4
Non, bah non, pay impôts. Je fais pas de
la je fais pas de l'évasion fiscale.
Est-ce qu'en face il y avait
Non, il y a pas de jalousie
avec votre public en face qu'il y avait
pas un certain dédain
en disant
Oui, je pense je me souviens alors ça me
rappelle un un collègue suisse qui avait
un
il y avait une personne à laquelle je
m'intéressais. Bon, qui préférait rester
en Suisse. Bon, donc je pouvais pas le
forcer. Euh et donc mon collègue suisse
l'entend, c'était il y a une vingtaine
d'années. Et à un moment donné euh la
personne lui dit à ce collègue suisse
euh "Écoutez, le juge français là qui
qui vous envoie,
il peut juste pas comprendre.
Il est pas équipé pour."
Non. Euh mieux que ça euh prendre un
café pour lui, ça signifie pour moi
prendre l'avion. Donc on n'est pas sur
la même planète.
Voilà. Bon, alors qu'est-ce que ça fait
d'aller perquisitionner ? Bah, si vous
voulez euh on constate, on saisit
aujourd'hui, on saisit beaucoup plus. Ça
c'est c'est quelque chose qu'on a
développé il y a il y a depuis une
vingtaine d'années parce qu'avant on
avait pas la culture de l'argent.
c'était la peine de prison, pas la peine
de prison ou l'amende ou voilà, on avait
que les on avait que ce réflexe là. Puis
un jour, on s'est dit mais euh on
pourrait peut-être toucher aux
porte-monnaie
sur trois générations.
Pourquoi sur trois générations ?
Parce que ça les dissuède un peu plus.
Oui, enfin il faut pour saisir, faut
quand même que ça soit l'argent qui a un
lien entre cet argent et et les les
infractions général du blanchiment, de
la corruption qui sont commises. On peut
dans certains cas étendre au patrimoine
et on le fait et on le fait de plus en
plus. Et
on a développé ce c'était pas dans la
culture française. C'est pas dans la
culture.
Est-ce que ça a été fait à dessin ?
Parce que vous parlez de la culture
française, mais la culture française
c'est quand vous tapez dans l'argent
publique, on vous coupe la tête.
Ah non, moi je vous parlais des la
culture des saisies, c'està-dire la
saisie des biens
des personnes poursuivies.
C'està-dire queon va quelque part et ben
on va saisir. Il y a une statuette qui
vaut 300000 € on la saisit. Il y a
l'appartement qui vaut quelques
millions, on met une hypothèque dessus.
Et si l'affaire tient, qu'elle va devant
le tribunal, si le tribunal l'estime
nécessaire, il confisque.
Oui. Voilà, c'est des sanctions
financières
qui sont parfois plus mal ressenties que
des peines de prison par les personnes
visées parce qu'elles ont mis des années
à constituer ce patrimoine, elles ont
tout mis dedans et on leur saisit tout.
Voilà. Donc faut avoir conscience de ça
aussi, c'est qu'on saisit aujourd'hui
beaucoup et d'ailleurs les vrais enjeux
de demain et c'est les saisies à
l'étranger,
les saisies dans les paradis offshore.
C'est pas un peu du wishpool sinking ça
?
C'est pas un veœ vœup pieux d'un juge
d'un juge droit
à Dubaï Oui oui à Dubaï oui. Euh
parce queà Dubaï euh en Suisse au
Luxembourg on peut saisir.
Alors je le dis pour nos auditeurs
euh qui seraient intéressés mais ils le
savent déjà. Ils sont bien conseillés
donc ils savent où il faut aller. Ouais.
Je vous dire il y a quelques années je
disais aller au Liban.
surtout pas
aujourd'hui. Oui. Donc voyez ça change.
Mais
parce que avant vous disiez Chypre,
c'est ça ?
Oui, il y a eu Chypre, vous avez eu
Chypre, c'est Chré. Non, mais il y a il
y a une instabilité de l'autre côté,
ce qui personnellement me réjouit que
l'argent qui est caché quelque part soit
jamais en totale sécurité. Où qu'il
soit,
par exemple, on va prendre l'exemple de
Chypre tous les deux puis on va faire
comme Macron, on va livrer quelques
petites anecdotes. D'accord ?
[grognement]
Comment ça se fait que avant le le on
appelle ça comment ? Je veux peut-être
confondre le mot, un raf, c'est ça ?
Quand par exemple la banque le vendredi
elle ferme puis bon p on s'arrange avec
les dettes puis le lendemain le du moins
le lundi vous réouvrez et puis vous avez
- 30 - 40 sur votre compte en banque.
Hm.
Comment ça se fait qu'il y a des gens
qui sont déjà au courant le jeudi et que
les avoirs
et il y a longtemps, attendez, vous
allez quand même pas, on n'ait pas la
naïveté de croire que ceux qui ont des
dizaines de millions euh cachés vont se
faire prendre. Je
ceux-là, on les prévient avant, mais
l'argent il est plus là quand quand on
bloque, l'argent est plus là. Oui, on va
bloquer les petits comptes bancaires,
des petites gens et cetera bien sûr ou
des gens qui sont qui vivent dans le
pays normalement et qui payent leurs
impôts. Ça ceuxa oui, ils vont ils vont
se trouver pris dans la NAS.
Comment vous savez ça ?
Mais je l'ai lu,
je l'ai pas constaté moi-même. J'ai pas
j'ai pas été à Chypre le jour où où il y
a eu Mais j'ai pu constater dans un de
dossiers que des gens qui avaient de
l'argent, beaucoup d'argent à chip, bah
il était reparti en Letonie par exemple.
Il y avait des oligarques russes. Vous
croyez que les oligarques russes, ils se
sont fait prendre la main dans le sac à
Chypre ? Non. Évidemment que non. Donc
vous savez, c'est très facile de de de
faire valcer l'argent d'une place
offshore à l'autre. Donc quand il y a un
risque à un moment donné, le gérant de
fortune, il est là pour ça. Il va
comprendre le truc, il va anticiper, il
va dire "Ouais, attention, ça arrive pas
comme ça." Euh c'est pas un tsunami qui
arrive euh comme ça en 10 secondes,
hein. Euh un tsunami euh euh financier,
une crise financière.
Donc là, là je vous pose ma question.
Est-ce que c'est pas un peu de
l'agitation de nos pouvoirs publics pour
dire attention ou des pouvoirs européens
pour dire attention, regardez le bra
vengeur et armé de notre justice ? a
fait fermer les comptes en banque à
Chypre pour choper le mauvais argent
alors que tous les gros se sont barrés
depuis bien longtemps.
Non mais à Chipre, on a jamais rien
saisi.
Non mais c'est ça.
Oui, l'argent était plus là. De toute
façon, c'est pas la peine. Donc euh
voilà. Mais vous
je pense qu'au Liban, c'est pareil.
Regardez ce qui s'est passé au Liban.
Vous pensez qu'il y a des grosses
fortunes qui ont été bloquées ? Pas
trop. Non.
Bon, je parle des fraudeurs, he je parle
de ceux qui voilà. Par contre, les
Libanais bloqués, il y en a plein là.
Les Libanais bloqués, il y en a plein
là.
Oui. Bah, on est même problématique qu'à
[__]
Mais aujourd'hui, je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui parce que sur ce, pardon de
vous couper, mais sur ce thème de
l'insécurité,
j'ai lu dans le monde récemment que les
Allemands avaient acheté 2 millions
d'euros un fich un fichier à Dubaï.
Vous l'avez pas lu cet article ?
Ah !
et qu'il s'apprêtait à le partager avec
d'autres d'autres pays parce qu'il y a
des gens du monde entier.
Il y a des Français dedans.
Pourquoi il y en aurait pas ?
En tout cas, s'il y en a,
j'espère que Bercy
en tirera toutes les conséquences
parce que depuis des années,
ceux qui ont caché de l'argent à
l'étranger,
ils peuvent passer
par merci. On leur on leur ouvre la
porte en disant "Bon, manifestez-vous
et si vraiment vous êtes dans la
génération spontanée, on vous taxera
moins que si on découvre que
il y a eu des possibilités d'ailleurs
Bercy a dit qu'il y a des milliards qui
étaient rentrés comme ça." Oui, parce
que le monde change quand même petit à
petit. Donc il y a des gens qui ont
peur.
Le monde change petit à petit. Mais
quand je vous entends, quand je vous
écoute, quand je travaille sur votre
dossier, quand je travaille sur
l'évasion fiscale, j'ai toujours cette
impression
que c'est le juge, la justice, les
policiers, ils sont toujours petits bras
à courir avec leurs petites jambes
derrière les gros touours. La justice a
toujours un train de retard. Mais là
c'est plus des trains là. Là c'est des
hyperloupes.
Oui mais à l'époque actuelle Oui. Bah
on va pas du tout à la même vitesse.
C'està-dire que d'abord vous savez que
la justice l'instruit des dossiers déjà
déjà faut qu'elle les connaisse ces
dossiers faut qu'elle en soi saisie.
souvent elle s'écouler des mois voir des
années avant qu'elle soit alertée
hein. Donc la la justice va pas
travailler sur quelque chose de on n'est
pas en flagrant d'élit, attention, on
n'est pas dans ce cas de figure parce
que tout ça s'est caché et d'ailleurs la
justice ne devrait jamais le connaître.
C'est par accident qu'un jour elle
apprend qu'il y a une corruption. Quand
vous avez une affaire de corruption,
qui va déposer plainte ? Le
corrompicorp anticorps.
Oui, mais encore faut-il
encore faut-il qu'anticorps le sache.
C'est pas écrit.
Donc ça on il y a il y a toujours ce
décalage dans le temps et c'est toute la
difficulté de ces enquêtes. C'estàd vous
arrivez des années plus tard, bon ok, je
vois l'argent, il est parti dans
Ltenstein, bah je vais aller je vais
aller demander au procureur de Linstein
de de me livrer les comptes. Bon puis
là, je vais apprendre que depuis 5 ans,
l'argent est parti à Singapour.
Je le saurai au bout de 6 mois, un an.
Qu'est-ce que je fais ? Bah, je vais à
Singapour et puis là, je vais apprendre
que c'est parti à Dubaï
il y a 3 ans. Bon,
vous aimez prendre l'avion pour
j'envoie, vous savez, on travaille avec
des mails avec des commissions je n'aime
pas les les grands voyages.
C'est fini le pigeon voyageur
ça. J'aime pour moi, j'ai jamais été
pigeon voyageur. Aurait peut-être dû
mais euh c'est quand même du temps de
perdu. C'est bon, pas toujours mais
Singapour c'était quand même loin. Bon
et là j'apprends que c à Dubaï sont
marrés les mecs en face. Non,
regardez le petit juge là qui gagne 5000
balles. Je suis en train de le faire
tourner. Il a 10 ans de retard
tranquillement et l'autre il est dans au
Turk et Kaiko. C'est en train de siroter
sa péan. Enfin, c'est je pense que quand
vous êtes poursuivi par la justice,
c'est pas
Vous craignez quand même quelque part
d'être pris à l'arrivée.
Bon, oui, moi je pense
une petite bouteille de un petit McDomal
Rudreer et ça passe.
Oui, effectivement, mais Dubaï si vous
voulez,
je poursuis sur mon exemple quand ça va
à Dubaï, Dubaï il répondent pas
du tout.
Non,
ils reçoivent les lettres mais ils
répondent jamais. Je sais même pas s'il
les reçoivent. En tout cas, oui, ils
doivent les recevoir mais j'ai jamais
obtenu un compte bancaire à Dubaï.
Ils extratent pas non plus
jusqu'à Alors, il semble qu' il y a une
extradition très récemment. Oh là !
Donc oui, mais euh mais maintenant
Dubaï, il y a il y a le fichier
qui est entre les mains des Allemands.
Donc
ça insécurise ces personnes-là et parce
que ils ont fraudé mais il y a une
insécurité. Ne pensez pas que ça se ça
se résume à un rapport d'argent entre le
juge et la et les personnes. Pas du
tout. C'est que le juge travaille pour
l'État,
pour nous.
La collectivité, c'est son rôle. Le
fraudeur, il travaille pour lui, il
utilise des moyens illégaux, pas vu, pas
pris, très bien, mais dès lors qu'il est
dans le collimateur du juge, il est
inquiet nécessairement. Il peut toujours
se dire "Je vais essayer de d'abord ça
lui coûte de l'argent parce que
transférer, cacher et cetera pour créer
des trust et cetera." C'est pas c'est un
coût tout ça. La fraude a un coût de
toute façon, mais il y a toujours le
risque qu'à l'arrivée l'argent soit pris
ou que soi-même on se fasse prendre. Et
puis si vous êtes à Dubaï, d'accord,
vous êtes à Dubaï, mais si vous si vous
avez un mandat d'arrêt international sur
le dos,
c'est moche Dubaï,
bah vous Bah oui, puis il fait chaud.
Donc euh bah oui, donc vous êtes vous
avez beau avoir un tas d'or, vous êtes
vous êtes bloqué à Dubaï donc
quelquefois vous pouvez être tenté de et
il y a des risques. Vous pouvez
peut-être pas aller voir votre famille
qui est en France, qui est ailleurs. B
c'est pas c'est pas anodin, vous voyez.
euh d'être d'être dans le cimateur de la
justice. Mais ce qui est important,
c'est que la justice le fasse, qu'elle
s'y intéresse. Ce qui est déplorable,
c'est qu'il y a des pays qui coopère
pas.
Lesquels ? Le Pérou.
Il y a le Pérou qui coopère pas. Il y a
il y a qui d'aut il y a J'ai jamais fait
de demande au Pérou.
Il y a Dubaï qui coopère pas.
Aujourd'hui là, le point noir, c'est
Dubaï le principal. Alors, il y en a
d'autres qui coopèrent.
Le Luxembourg, il coopère.
Oui.
Avec des freins sur les pieds ou en
tongue ?
Ils sont en costume.
Oui. Ouis. D'accord. Mais non, coopère
les juges coopèrent
mais il coopère le temps de laisser le
temps de partir, il coopère quoi juste
pour la forme ?
Non non, il coopère plus que pour la
forme. Les juges les juges sont
efficaces au Luxembourg simplement au
Luxembourg comme dans d'autres pays,
certains autres pays européens, il y a
un système de recours. C'est-à-dire que
les banques visées, les personnes
peuvent contester les demandes du juge
français et ça ralentit considérablement
le process. C'estàd qu'il va falloir des
mois voire un an pour obtenir les
relevés bancaires parce qu'il y aura une
contestation ouverte dans le le pays.
Mais c'est la législation du pays qui
qui veut ça. Je suis personnellement
pour la suppression de ces recours à
partir du moment où on est au sein de
l'Europe entre démocraties. Et vous
savez, on a lancé en 96.
Je peux vous couper ?
Oui.
Vous êtes pas un peu bisounours là ?
Peut-être
quand on voit le Danemark écouter notre
copine allemande, chef d'état de son
état,
est-ce que vous pensez pas un petit peu
que c'est, je je vais
[raclement de gorge] être vulgaire
encore, je suis infiniment désolé.
Est-ce que c'est pas un peu chacun son
cul et Dieu pour tous ?
Est-ce que l'Europe c'est pas un petit
peu le truc qu'on marque sur la
plaquette publicitaire et que machin
quand il y a du R
Moi je suis un européen convaincu.
Je je suis je suis partisan que l'Europe
est davantage de prérogative, que les
États arrêtent de de se de rester dans
leur frontière
et c'est tellement vrai en matière de
justice he que je suis tellement heurté
à des obstacles de frontières pour
retrouver de l'argent pour identifier
des comptes là à tout près en Suisse au
Luxembourg au Leninstein à Gibraltar ou
je ne sais où. On est dans l'Europe. Bon
et là j'ai des obstacles. Moi, je suis
pour l'Europe. Voilà, je suis Il y a un
procureur européen qui existe depuis peu
et ce procureur européen, il a
malheureusement des pouvoirs extrêmement
limités. Mais parce que les États
veulent pas transférer leur pouvoir,
voilà, c'est quelque chose de régalien.
Et ben personnellement, je dénonce ça
parce que il faut qu'on avance. Et
d'ailleurs, c'est ce que je propose moi,
c'est que la France prenne des
initiatives
au sein de l'Europe
pour d'abord pour harmoniser fiscalement
tout cela, mais surtout pour exiger des
pays comme Chypre, Malte qui fassent le
ménage chez eux. l'Europe devrait
pouvoir l'imposer. Voilà qui est des
enquêteurs chez eux que quand il y a des
banques qui font du blanchim on
sanctionne ces banques, on sanctionne
les dirigeants, on se contente pas de
répondre aux demandes de juges étrangers
quand ils ont un cas particulier qui a
un véritable ménage et je pense que
l'Europe, elle peut montrer l'exemple à
ce niveau-là.
Peut-être qu'elle monte les dents, non ?
un peu comme les États-Unis,
bah elle pourra le faire si elle fait le
ménage chez elle et ensuite on pourra
peut-être exporter notre système parce
qu'actuellement c'est le contraire qui
se passe hein. C'est les c'est les
Américains qui prennent des initiatives.
Je vous ai parlé de Joe Biden tout à
l'heure et l'Europe qui suit.
Des fois ils prennent un peu des
initiatives pour leur propre business,
non ? Vous avez pas remarqué ça ?
Leurs intérêts sont menacés quelque part
s'il bougent. Mais s'il bougent, ils
font bouger les autres. Par contre,
l'Europe, elle fait rien bouger. Faut
voter pour qui pour que ça bouge ?
ça boule. Bah, il faut voter pour des
gens qui sont pro européens.
Vous avez voté pour qui aux prochaines
élections présidentielles ?
Ah mais attendez, moi j'ai le j'ai le
bulletin secret dans l'urne, j'y tiens.
C'est compliqué de de cuisiner un juge.
Non,
il y a toujours une défense quelque
part, vous savez. Et et à la limite,
j'ai le droit au silence. Donc c'est ma
dernière parade.
Ne regardez pas le technicien, il va pas
vous aider. Non mais je vous regarde
[rires]
Bon, on continue.
Revenons, revenons à la à la traque. La
traque du malfaiteur, la traque de
l'escroc, la traque du traître. Est-ce
que les la police et les services des
renseignements vous aident un peu ?
surtout les services de renseignement.
On dit toujours qu'il y a toujours un
service de renseignement dans chaque
salle de trading, dans chaque
gestionnaire de fortune. Est-ce que les
services vous ont aidé ?
Non,
jamais.
Non, non, non. De toute façon, c'est le
juge, il intervient toujours euh d'une
façon officielle,
c'estàdire qu'il faut qu'il passe par
une demande officielle dans l'autre
pays. Ça ça va aller chez un juste.
Quelque fois, ça met du temps parce
qu'il faut que ça passe pas le
ministère.
Oui, quelquefois même le ministère des
affaires étrangères, le ministère de la
justice. Donc il y a pas beaucoup de
pays, il y a pas de contact direct. Donc
déjà ça ça serait un progrès si les
juges pouvaient entre en tout cas dans
les démocraties pouvaient se contacter
entre eux.
Il y a le problème du temps. Voilà,
c'est c'est le temps. Mais le juge s'il
passe pas par ses voix officielles, il
passe pas.
Le juge il est il applique la loi donc
il doit la respecter. Il y a des
conventions internationales, il doit les
respecter. Donc le fait qu'il y a pas de
contact direct, ça ça freine son action.
Alors, ceci dit, il y a il y a des il y
a des policiers détachés dans un dans
pratiquement dans tous les pays.
Je me souviens par exemple d'avoir un
d'avoir eu besoin de renseignement en
Colombie euh et je les ai eu parce que
il y avait un officier, on appelle ça,
un officier de liaison qui a qui
connaissait le procureur, qui m'a
facilité les contacts et cetera. Donc ça
a pris un certain temps mais j'y suis
arrivé. Euh voilà.
Donc pas de service de renseignement qui
vous facilite l'accès à certaines
informations.
Non,
zéro.
Les policiers peuvent avoir quelquefois
des renseignements mais euh c'est les
douanes aussi les par les douanes
comment
les doues ils bossent bien.
Oui, tout à fait. Mais elles font une
demande à aux douers de l'autre pays. Il
y a il y a des renseignements mais tant
que c'est pas validé, ça ne vaut que ça
ne vaut que comme renseignement. Il faut
pour le valider avoir les comptes, les
relevés de comptes transmis
officiellement par le procureur du pays.
Si vous avez pas ça, euh la personne
pourra toujours contester, dire que ça
n'a pas de valeur, ça n'est pas certifié
et vous pourrez pas faire tenir un
dossier comme ça. C'est toute la
difficulté. C'est qu'il faut des années
pour euh après vous allez me dire une
justice à deux vitesses. Bah oui, il
faut des années pour démanteler des des
réseaux très complexes auxquels on
comprend rien au départ.
Si on y arrive, c'est pas toujours
gagné.
Revenons au secret défense. Est-ce que
vous avez suivi un petit peu cette
petite polémique sur l'accès aux
archives ?
Non,
vous savez, on a essayé, du moins
certains ont essayé de de reporter
l'accès aux archives à leur bon vouloir.
C'est-à-dire que les services pouvaient
euh
laisser classifier certaines
informations. Alors, jusque advitamnem
si le le plaisir leur venait. Qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez de ça ? Je sais pas,
je je pas du tout suivi le problème.
Moi, je vous ai dit ce que je pensais du
secret défense. Je comprends qu'on
puisse protéger
par exemple des informateurs à
l'étranger, des choses sensibles et
cetera. Évidemment,
ça me paraît légitime, mais ce que je ne
comprends pas, c'est qu'on applique le
secret défense dans le versement de
commission internationale. Voilà, c'est
sauf si c'est pour financer les
opérations antiterroristes et cetera.
Ça, je peux le comprendre. Mais quand
c'est des commissions qui sont versées
et que derrière euh il y a de la
corruption, ça je le comprends pas.
D'autant que dans ces six réseaux peut
aussi y avoir de l'argent qui reviennent
en France. Évidemment, c'est
c'est un peu tout le principe. Non,
c'est pas frais dans tous les cas. On
peut pas généralisez pas. Il faut pas
gêner, vous savez, faut jamais
Moi, j'ai toujours essayé de de ne je
vais au bout mes dossiers, je suis allé
au bout mais j'ai pas d'a priori, voilà
parce que je peux aussi me tromper. Il y
a aussi des gens honnêtes. Il y a aussi
quand je dis honnête, il y a aussi moi
j'ai vu des gens par exemple qui
géraient une caisse noire d'une
entreprise à l'étranger, des salariés,
un homme de confiance qui faisait ce
qu'on lui disait mais il prenait pas un
centime au passage.
Il a fait de la prison.
Non.
question internet,
c'est un exécutant maintenant, mais d'un
certain niveau, il connaît pas forcément
toutes les les destinations, les pour
qui, les pourquoi, mais les dirigeants
avaient confiance en lui parce que il
savait que la parce que quand vous avez
une caisse noire, celui qui a la caisse
noire, il peut détourner l'argent donc
faut quelqu'un de confiance. Voilà,
qu'on puisse retrouver
donc c'est comme ça qu'on retrouve des
gens honnêtes dans ces dans ces
circuits, dans ces réseaux. Donc on peut
pas mettre tout le monde dans le même
sac. Le juge doit toujours essayer de
comprendre qui fait quoi et pourquoi et
à qui ça profite.
Question internet qui est un peu longue.
Je travaille sur le marché de l'art,
vente de toile de maître. Que
pensent-t-il de la 5e directive LCBFT
AML 5 en anglais mise en place le 10
janvier dans le cadre de la lutte
antiblanchiment ? Alors je réponds, je
suis désolé, je suis à la retraite
depuis 2 ans, je ne connais pas cette
directive.
Est-ce que vous avez une expérience de
blanchiment dans les œuvres d'art ? Si
oui, est-ceque
?
J'ai pas beaucoup vu ça dans mes
dossiers
puisque cette loi demande
mais ça j'ai vu ce que j'ai vu c'est des
opérations de blanchiment qui étaient
couvertes par des prétendus achat et
ventes d'œuvre d'art qui étaient fictive
c'estàd que c'est un banqu
tableau ou des petits tableaux
des tableaux oui par exemple oui par
exemple au au Lenstein
il y avait des des grands des gros
transferts d'argent sur des fraudeur
Et au Lichtenin, il y a des législations
antiblanchiment.
Ah oui, parce que là aussi on a avancé
hein. Bon, malgré tout donc les
fraudeurs et les banques qui facilitent
les fraudes, il faut juste pas se faire
prendre. Bon, donc ils avaient trouvé
euh cette histoire de vente d'œuvre
d'art, c'estàd que la personne
justifiait des sorties importantes de
fonds par des fausses des faux
certificats d'achat ou de vente d'œuvre
d'art. Donc là, on était dans le le
blanchiment et la banque pouvait dire
"Mais non, mais il a acheté un tableau,
voilà, j'ai j'ai le papier et tout et
voilà." Donc c'est ça, vous savez, on
est beaucoup dans l'apparence.
C'est ça le problème, c'est que dans ces
pays qui sont soumis à des législations,
parce qu'il y a des législations en
Suisse, au Luxembourg, au Lenstein, vous
savez, plus vous légiférez, plus le
frôur va essayer de trouver des failles
dans le système. Donc le banquier
pour répondre à à notre personne parce
que j'ai vu c'est voilà le cas où j'ai
trouvé des ventes d'œuvre d'art mais
c'était des fausses, c'est pour
justifier des sorties de fond, voilà, et
qui partaient sur bien autre chose que
des achats d'œuvre d'art. Euh la le
banquier lui il est tenu il a il a quand
même une un contrôle quelque part les
complance des des ça existe la
prévention antiblanchiment donc il faut
qu'il puisse dire je savais pas
oui j'ai fait ce qu'il fallait pour
m'assurer que la personne n'était pas en
fraude et cetera il m'a déclaré que j'ai
pas trop de pouvoir il est pas sur les
listes noires
il a justifié des des transferts
importants par des ventes d'œuvres
d'art. D'ailleurs, j'ai regardé la
regardez, j'ai la copie des des des
pièces et tout. Donc oui oui, mais si
vous voulez
prouver après que le banquier était
complice, qui savait que et cetera. Bon,
c'est pas forcément il va pas forcément
le déclarer spontanément, voyez. Et puis
en plus euh quand je dis qu'il faut
faire le ménage, euh il faut que ces
pays-là fassent le ménage contre les
banques qui se livrent à ce type
d'activité. Est-ce qu'elles peuvent le
faire ? Est-ce que c'est pas un petit
peu, vous savez bien
sûr que tout le monde peut le faire
comme comme est-ce que c'est pas un peu
comme les anciennes voitures Renault les
anciennes voitures Renault là quand on
vous leur coup le SP, elles arrivaient
plus à rouler là.
Est-ce que c'est pas un peu le des États
qui en vivent ?
Oui, exactement.
Ils en vivent. Ben bien sûr, mais c'est
toute l'hypocrisie du système.
Il faut faire comme si au maximum parce
qu'il y a des lois antiblanchiment mais
il y a encore des des établissements qui
continuent ce type d'activité ou qui
veulent pas dire. Regardez au Luxembourg
récemment, il y a eu le monde encore une
fois fait état de de d'obligations qui
étaient pas respectées par certaines
certaines banques au Luxembourg,
certains établissements.
Mais vous savez, je vais vous dire euh
il faut savoir où est le curseur
aujourd'hui. Voilà, c'estàdire que il y
a des délocalisations. C'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre, c'est que il y a des
avoirs par exemple au Luxembourg où je
l'ai vu en Suisse. Il y avait des gens
qui avaient des avoirs en Suisse et puis
dans les années 2009 2010, il y a eu des
conventions signées entre pays
européens, entre l'Europe, la Suisse et
cetera et l'argent est parti. Mais
le le la gestion de l'argent a continué
à se faire en Suisse. C'estàdire que
vous aviez
vous par exemple, vous aviez 3 millions
pas gros, hein, c'est un petit client, 3
millions de francs suisse dans une
banque suisse. Très bien. Vous l'avez
pas déclaré, c'est fraudé. Bon, il y a
des conventions qui sont signées.
Votre votre banquier va vous dire c'est
pas grave, je vais le mettre au nom
d'une société panaméienne, je vais vous
transférer l'argent sur un compte à
Singapour.
Et je vais mettre en plus, je vais faire
mieux que ça. J'ai pu être le gérant
officiel. Le gérant officiel c'est
quelqu'un qui est à Dubaï et puis on va
mettre une cité des séchelles entre deux
pour faire l'interface.
Ni vu ni connu.
C'est ce que j'appelle une
délocalisation.
que si
je me souviens, vous allez comprendre
tout de suite l'exemple
me souviens problème en Suisse à une
époque déjà quelques années mais en face
ça serait d'actualité le juge Suisse
arrive dans perquisition dans la banque
à la demande d'un juge français et il
voit à l'écran de l'ordinateur les
relevés du compte qui l'intéresse et il
veut saisir
mais le banquier lui dit "Mais non mais
vous pouvez pas, c'est un compte qui est
ouvert aux île caillan.
Donc il faut, moi je peux pas, je
voudrais j'aimerais vous le donner bien
sûr, je coopère avec la justice mais
j'ai pas le droit. Ce qu'il faut faut
d'abord que vous demandiez
l'autorisation de la tournée générale du
Caillement.
Procureur général
à Tourné. Voilà. Procureur général.
Voilà. Euh parce que
informatiquement,
j'ai une copie du compte ici, mais euh
et il y a eu tout un débat là-dessus.
Moi, je pars du principe que si je vois
un ordinateur, je prends ce qu'il y a
dedans.
Je le dis pour ceux qui nous écoutent,
ceux qui nous écoutent, s'ils veulent
gérer leur compte à Singapour de leur
ordinateur, si j'arrive, je prendrai.
Voilà. Alors, ça n'aura peut-être pas la
valeur évidemment du relevé de compte
qu'il va falloir que je demande à
Singapour pour avoir l'officiel,
l'original certifié par là-bas. Mais euh
j'ai l'information,
je fais une petite diversion. Et le
budget du ministère de la de de la
justice en France, il est comment ? Il
est bien, il est pas bien ? C'est digne
d'un pays du tiers monde ? Est-ce que
c'est fait à dessin ? C'est-à-dire qu'on
donne pas à manger à son chien comme ça
il est un peu moins virulent sur le
terrain de chasse ou il est un peu plus
virulent sur le terrain de chasse.
Comment ça se passe là ? Est-ce qu'on a
pas un peu le ministère de la justice
qui part chasser
h
de grands prédateurs avec des petits
curdents ?
H
parce que des il y a il y a du vrai dans
ce que dans ce que vous dites mais c'est
un peu réducteur. Pourquoi ? Parce que
vous savez la la la question des moyens,
OK, elle se pose. Il y a pas qu'une
question de moyen.
Mais 5000 balles un juge,
il y a une question le problème c'est 1
million.
Non, ça changera rien. Ça changera rien.
Ça change rien de toute façon milliard.
Non. Ah ah 1 milliard.
Non
non
non non, ça change rien. Non là là n'est
pas le problème. Le problème c'est que
il faut des moyens d'abord faut des
juges qui il faut des juges des grefiers
et cetera. Bon, il y en a alors est-ce
qu'il y en a pas assez peut-être, mais
il y a aussi la les outils dont on
dispose. Euh vous pouvez euh multiplier
par 10 euh le budget de la justice. Euh
ça va changer quelque chose le jour où
je vais demander à Dubaï de me donner
les relevés du tout de compte d'une
personne qui a fraudé des dizaines de
millions. Ça changera rien. Donc il y a
pas qu'un problème de moyen. C'est pas
parce que vous allez mettre 50
enquêteurs sur la même affaire au lieu
de 10 que ça va changer quoi que ce
soit. C'est pas un problème. Vous savez,
il y a une technicité
et je moi j'ai jamais été je pense que
j'ai jamais eu beaucoup de moyens en ce
sens que j'ai jamais mobilisé beaucoup
d'enquêteurs parce que je travaillais
par moi-même. Mais je me disais ça sert
à rien. Euh ce qui compte c'est de
comprendre ce qui se passe et d'aller
chercher à l'étranger les informations.
Et il y a rien de plus frustant que ne
pas les obtenir alors qu'on a fait tout
ce qu'il fallait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour.
Donc dire c'est les moyens, c'est les
moyens. Oui, mais c'est moyen peut-être
pour les divorces, pour tout ça. Il y a
peut-être pas peut-être. Mais il y a
aussi euh d'abord regardez au niveau des
ordinateurs.
Là, c'est là qu'on a besoin de d'outils
performants. Mais entendez par outil
outil de renseignement, outil pour
déchiffer,
outil de travail. C'est il vous faut un
PC.
Comment
il vous faut un PC, une connexion
internet ou il faut quelque chose pour
faire ? Par exemple, si on utilise
l'euro, on peut saisir vos données. Si
vous utilisez un un composant européen
dans votre ordinateur, hop, on peut ce
problème d'ordinateur de moyen, je le
vois surtout au niveau des greffiers.
C'est-à-dire que on est encore
aujourd'hui par exemple à la lettre
recommandée avec accusé de réception.
Petit pigeon.
Et oui, donc vous avez des greffiers qui
passent leur temps à envoyer des lettres
recommandées avec de réception et de
regarder si la cuisine de réception est
signée. On en est encore là. J'ai j'ai
des j'ai souvenir de de collègues qui
qui étaient dans les dans les dossiers
où il y avait des milliers de victimes,
pas dans le terrorisme mais des des
milliers de victimes. Bon et un jour je
je vois ça sa greffière, il y avait il y
avait un paquet comme ça de l'être
commandé avec récipion parce qu'à chaque
fois qu'il leur donnait une expertise,
fallait le notifier à toutes les
parties.
Les sites intranet sécurisés, on connaît
pas. Bah oui. Non mais voilà. Alors vous
avez donné des moyens c'estàd que vous
allez pouvoir envoyer plus de lettres
commandées dans des délais plus rapides.
Non mais réfléchissons 2 minutes, il y a
des moyens autres. Oui, ça vous fait
hurler parce que vous êtes vous êtes
branché certainement beaucoup plus que
moi. Mais c'est ça euh voilà, la
justice, elle souffre de ça, de cette on
ressaisit 50 fois les mêmes choses.
On a modifié les les les systèmes, les
logiciels et cetera de pour le pour les
greffiers par exemple.
instruction
et j'entendais tout le temps les
greffières d'instruction dire le système
qu'on nous a collé on passe plus de
temps qu'avant.
Alors, je veux bien qu'on multiplie les
greffières, mais c'est pour c'est pour
qu'elle travaille comme comme on
travaille à 20 ans, alors qu'il y a des
outils, arrêtez 5 minutes et
réfléchissons comment on peut faciliter
le travail avec des moyens beaucoup plus
modernes. Cette technicité, vous savez,
l'administration, elle est toujours en
retard, hein. C'est ça le problème aussi
de qu'il faut voir. Il y a ça et puis a
il y a le problème du
de dans ces affaires là, puisqu'on parle
de ces affaires là, de la coopération
des des autres pays et du défaut de
coopération.
Alors le défaut de coopération, est-ce
que vous êtes un peu comme nous ? Quand
on fait du défaut de coopération pour de
l'évasion fiscale, est-ce que ça doit
être pris comme un acte de guerre ?
Le défaut de coopération,
ça doit être pris comme un acte de
guerre. Mais non, mais on devrait mettre
au pas les pays qui coopèrent pas.
Ah voilà, on commence à comment on fait
pour les comment on fait ? On envahit le
Luxembourg, on fait sortir nos charmes.
Mais non, mais attendez, les économistes
le savent mieux que moi. Vous vous ne
reconnaissez pas les transactions avec
ces pays. Point bar. La question que je
vous pose, c'est on est capable, nous
les Français, les Européens avec nos
petits bras
de mettre des sanctions au Mola iranien,
de mettre des sanctions à Poutine à
Moscou, de mettre des sanctions à
d'autres et nous
mais pas là ma vie.
Ah bah comment ça se fait ? Mais comment
ça se fait ?
Mais parce qu'on veut pas les mettre.
Ah merci. Pourquoi on veut pas les
mettre ? Mais parce qu'il y a pas de
volonté politique.
Ah mais non mais arrêtez de dire volonté
et politique dans la même phrase s'il
vous plaît.
Volé politique internationale, ça vous
va mieux comme ça ?
C'est mieux.
Voilà. [rires]
Pourquoi il y a pas de volonté ? Il faut
que ce soit il faut que ce soit le le le
citoyen
qui s'en empare pour que la volonté des
politiques suiv.
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait là ? Parce que ça
saigne nos état. Faudit déjà faudrait
déjà que les citoyens
une conscience internationale.
Non mais qui se cache pas Oui. qui se
cache pas derrière leur nationalisme. Je
pense que tout ce qui est nationaliste
s'oppose à la coopération
internationale. C'est la première cause.
Est-ce que le patriotisme c'est la même
chose ?
Attention,
moi [grognement] j'ai du respect pour
les les gens qui ont fait la guerre pour
tout ça, qui se sont battus, qui on est
libre aujourd'hui grâce à eux. Donc je
mélangerai pas les concepts. Je dis
simplement pour moi le ceux qui veulent
aujourd'hui euh fermer les frontières se
trompe.
C'est mon opinion après avoir connu
toutes ces affaires là. Ou alors on
continue parce que on vit dans un monde
mondialisé. J'y peux rien. Il est
mondialisé simplement il n'est pas
réglementé. Il est pas contrôlé nulle
part. Alors je pas avoir l'air d'un d'un
communiste attardé en disant il faut
mettre au pas tout le monde avec un
pouvoir unique. Pas ça du tout. Je dis
simplement qu'il faut assurer des règles
du jeu partout dans le monde, elles le
sont pas. Donc on a une forme de
libéralisme qui aboutit à des excès mais
que qu'on voit aujourd'hui mais avec des
démultipliés parce qu'on sait même pas
tout ce qui est fraudé. Commençons par
aller chercher l'argent de la fraude. Et
s'il y avait une volonté politique
internationale réelle, me dites pas
qu'il y a pas de solution. Il y en a qui
pas obligé.
Bah par exemple, on si vous dites à un
pays comme les îles caillemment, c'est
c'est ça fait peur les îles caillemment,
il y a pas besoin d'envirement aux
îlement toutes les transactions avec les
îles caillant avec les sociétés
immatriculées là-bas qui sont des
fausses sociétés des coquilles vides
avec des banques qui ont leur siège
là-bas sont on refuse toute transcurren
taxé à 95 %.
Oui mais oui ça peut être une une
solution. Enfin, il y a des solutions.
Après, il faut techniquement qu'elle
soit possible. Quoi d'autre ?
Bah, des sanctions commerciales. On
commerce plus avec des pays qui ce
comportement là. On leur met la
pression. Enfin, vous les connaissez
mieux que moi toutes les sanctions qu'on
peut, il y a toute une gamme de
sanctions euh qu'on peut qu'on peut
appliquer. C'est une question d'ordre
public international
mais on en est loin aujourd'hui et il
faudra bien que le monde change. Mais
vous savez, on pourrait parler
d'environnement, c'est pareil.
Si vous vous faites le ménage chez vous,
vous réduisez l'empreinte carbone et
c'est OK. Et si le voisin en fait 10
fois plus,
qu'est-ce qui à quoi ça sert ? Il faut
bien qu'il y a une communauté
internationale qui signe des conventions
qui s'accord et qui fixe un minimum de
règles à respecter et même là d'ailleurs
elles sont pas respectées. Donc on en
est loin. Mais je pense que le monde il
ira vers ça si on réfléchit. Il y aura
une régulation internationale. C'est
inévitable.
Je vous donne un exemple.
Pandémie internationale.
Oui, voilà. Exemple.
Pandémie internationale. Des masques
transitent par notre tarmac
saisi par les douanes. Des masques qui
nous étaient pas destinés.
Là, c'est du chacun pour soi
et du pour tous.
Oui. Puis il y a ceux qui produisent les
vaccins, ceux qui les produisent pas,
ceux qui Non, mais il y a pas il y a pas
eu dans la pandémie une gestion mondiale
alors que c'est un problème mondial.
Parce que si si vous réglez le problème
chez vous et que le voisin ça ça se
répend,
on est on est interconnecté, on y peut
rien. C'est comme ça. Vacciné, vous
vous êtes pas obligé de répondre. Bah
depuis depuis le début, j'essaie de
répondre à vos questions, de pas
invoquer le silence. Je suis vacciné
d'ailleurs, c'est pour ça que je porte
pas de masque.
Mais vous avez aussi des distances de
sécurité
en plus. [grognement]
Évidemment que je suis vacciné. Pour
moi, c'est un acte citoyen se faire
vacciner. D'abord, on se protège mais on
protège les autres.
les personnes âgées, les personnes les
personnes à risque, il y en a. Bon, donc
on peut c'est puis on sait très bien que
s'il y a 80 % de de vaccinés, le
problème est réglé. Alors, je comprends
pas moi les les gens qui veulent pas se
faire vacciner.
Question internet. Pourquoi
n'ordonne-ton pas un casier judiciaire
vierge pour nos dirigeants ?
N'ordonne-on pas
Pourquoi on donne pas un casier
judiciaire vierge pour nos politiques ?
Bah la plupart le sont
quoi ? Vierge ou politique pour
Attendez, pour avoir un caser
judiciaire, faut avoir été condamné.
La plupart sont condamnés, c'est ça ?
Non, la plupart ne le sont pas.
Et ceux qui sont condamnés ?
Alors, ceux qui sont condamnés, il y a
il y a la possibilité pour les
tribunaux, ils le font maintenant,
d'ordonner l'interdiction de de se
présenter à des élections,
l'inégibilité, ce qui est nouveau aussi.
Bah je pense que le l'un des premiers
cas c'était justement le dossier dont je
vous parlais que j'ai instruit à
l'époque la FA urba avec Henri
Emmanueli. Il a eu 2 ans je crois
d'inéibilité
ce qui a été très contesté à l'époque
y compris dans la dialectique.
Oui.
On est passé d'inculpation à mise en
examen.
Oui, exactement. On a changé le terme.
Avant le citoyen lambda, il se fait
inculper, ça gêne personne. Bon, le
président de l'Assemblée nationale est
inculpé, ça gêne. Il est mise en examen.
Il était inculpé à l'époque. Je l'ai
inculpé mais c'est après qu'ils ont se
dit alors
c'est comme ça ça marche comme ça. Je je
sais plus sur quoi j'étais parti.
C'est fait exprès.
Le
casier judiciaire vierge pour les
politiques. Oui. Mais
je pense que la vraie sanction c'est
celle c'est l'inibilité. Si vous avez
détourné des fonds, les tribunaux
maintenant, voilà je ce que je voulais
vous développer tout à l'heure, ils ont
la possibilité de de prononcer
l'inibilité pour un certain temps.
Après après qu'est-ce que vous voulez
après ? Une peine, elle est jamais
éternelle, elle est jamais
elle peut être définitive mais elle est
toujours limitée dans sa durée. Prenez
quelqu'un qui a commis un vol qui va
faire 2 ans de prison, il a le droit de
travailler après ces 2 ans de prison.
Mais il y a une différence entre un un
pilleur de un voleur de poule et un
pilleur de foule.
Pour moi, il y a qu'un droit pénal. Il y
a une égalité de tous. J'ai essayé de
l'appliquer.
La loi est la même pour tous.
[grognement]
Question internet
que je vais peut-être d'ailleurs
compléter. Question : une
instrumentalisation de la justice
est-elle en cours ? Justice à deux
vitesses. Le cafillon DSK garde des
soins aux charges de ralentir les
affaires en cours pour l'interrogation.
Moi je la je la je je la je l'amende un
petit peu quand on a vu les gilets
jaunes être victime de techniques de
contre-insurrection digne des pays du
tiersmonde en France quand on les a vu
se prendre des balles dans la tête
perdre des mains, se prendre des
grenades et j'en passais des meilleurs.
Tout de suite ils étaient jugés. Tout de
suite ils étaient en prison
et hop et puis de la prise en ferme pour
certains.
S'il nous écoutent on leur passe le
bonjour.
Comment ça se fait que le petit gilet
jaune français pas les sourcils quand je
dis ça ? On a des copains détenus.
Comment ça se fait que le petit gilet
jaune tout de suite il se fait juger
et le gros requin
il lui faut des décennies ?
Des décennies ? Vous exagérez peut-être
[rires]
des décennies ?
C'est beaucoup plus compliqué. Ah, on va
prendre le temps d'expliquer tout ça. H
euh
une manifestation, quelqu'un qui se fait
prendre, bon qui commet un
qui une dégradation, on le voit, on le
sait, ça c'est pas très compliqué à
juger. Ça peut être jugé rapidement. Il
y a des procédures qui sont qui sont
rapides
sans vouloir parler uniquement des
gilets jaunes, mais prenez quelqu'un qui
commet un vol simple, il se fait prendre
la main dans le sac, il va être jugé
rapidement. Quelqu'un qui détourne des
fonds,
quelqu'un qui tape sa femme et qui se
fait main courante et main courante et
main courante et qui finit qui finit
qui finit par mettre un coup de fusil ou
qui finit par imoler sa femme chose.
Oui.
C'est quoi ? Parce que c'est facile.
Le mec qui tape sur sa femme, on prend
un pop, on met en zonzon.
C'est alors c'est la même chose, non ?
Oui mais bon attendez pas je peux pas je
peux pas généraliser. Il y a peut-être
des cas particuliers mais il y a aussi
des gens qui tapent leurs femmes qui se
retrouvent en prison. Bon euh moi je ne
sais pas puis euh
mélangeons pas le problème. Moi je vous
explique simplement pourquoi il y a
certains faits simples qui peuvent être
jugés rapidement et d'autres qui
prennent beaucoup plus de temps. Je vous
ai expliqué tout à l'heure les paradis
fiscaux. Moi, vous me donnez une enquête
compliquée à faire.
En trempant le maillot, si j'ai un beau
montage en face de moi, j'en ai pour 4
ans minimum.
Un beau montage. Vous respectez le
travail qui a été fait en face ? Bah
oui, parce que il me donne du mal. Donc
euh enfin, je respecte, je le découvre,
je je vois les mais j'en apprends tous
les jours parce que ça change tout le
temps, ça change de pays, ça change de
avec le temps, ça a considérablement
évolué. Et je dirais que plus les juges
sont allés sur ce terrain-là et plus on
a sophistiqué les circuits de l'autre
côté, hein. Bon, donc il faut des
années. Qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise ? On peut pas juger.
Si vous voulez juger quelqu'un qui a
détourné 100 millions d'euros, vous
comme ça tout de suite, vous pouvez pas.
Vous avez pas les éléments.
J'ai pas une caméra qui l'a filmé en
train de de faire toutes ses transferts
de compte. J'ai pas ça. Donc il faut
aller chercher l'information. et le
gilet jaune qui lance un caillou sur des
CRS ultra barricadé armé avec des
casques.
Après, attendez, moi je c'est dit tout à
l'heure, je ne critique pas les
décisions de justice. Les juges, ils
apprécient. Voilà, ils peuvent estimer
que c'est caractérisé, que c'est pas
caractérisé. Après, qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise ? S'ils estiment
devoir sanctionner, ils sanctionnent.
Voilà, c'est il y a une loi, elle est la
même pour tout le monde.
Est-ce que la loi est instrumentalisée
par le pouvoir politique ?
La loi, elle est votée par le pouvoir
politique
et les juges, faut comprendre aussi que
les juges, ils sont indépendants dans
leur décision.
On peut pas leur dire faites c ou faites
ça.
On peut leur mettre un peu la pression.
Non,
genre tu auras pas d'avancement, tu
Non, tu es pas sur des affaires de
comparition immédiate.
Non, le juge il estime en conscience que
avec son équation personnelle
et d'ailleurs souvent ils sont plusieurs
et puis vous parlez, on peut parler
aussi puisque vous faisiez transition
sur les faits les plus graves savoir que
par exemple les faits de viol, d'inceste
et cetera, ce sont des jurés qui
prononcent les peines. jamais oublié ça.
Les jurés, c'est les citoyens, ils sont
majoritaires.
Donc les juges, les juges, c'est les
citoyens tirés au sort.
Bon, s'ils estiment devoir mettre 10 ans
alors que vous vous considérez qu'il
fallait mettre 30 ans ou l'inverse,
c'est c'est le verdict des des citoyens.
La justice, je vais vous dire la justice
dans dans l'appréciation de la peine,
c'est quelque chose de très compliqué
parce que on touche de l'humain.
C'est pas un ordinateur qui applique
automatiquement les peines. Non, ça
existe pas.
Vous volez ma prochaine question. Bien
vu.
Oui, j'anticipe. Voyez, je vous venir.
[rires] Allez-y, je vous en prie.
Posez-la.
La justice. Merci.
La justice par un robot, par une
intelligence artificielle dans le futur,
est-ce que ça vous fait peur ou
non ? Ça me fait peur.
Ça me fait peur
ce que j'ai ce que j'ai aimé dans ce
métier justement, c'est qu'on est on
apprécie une situation qui n'est jamais
la même que celle du voisin.
On on juge une personne, il y a les
faits.
Euh la personne elle-même, elle peut
avoir été l'objet de ses vis quand elle
était jeune et cetera. Bon, elle peut
aussi euh avoir des difficultés, être en
crise et cetera. Donc elle peut aussi
s'être s'être ressobilisée.
La justice par anticipation.
Qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par
anticipation ?
Bon euh on vous fait une petite mise à
jour très triviale. Imaginez-vous que
vous laissez des datas sur les réseaux
sociaux avec votre téléphone.
Les datas ? Oui, des des traces. Des
traces de
des traces de vous avez borné sur un
téléphone portable
à la grande borne. Vous avez borné chez
un dealer machin.
D'accord. Euh euh vous avez lu tel type
de livre, vous avez posté tel type de
commentaire sur Facebook et là
l'algorithme que mon voisin de gauche a
a pissé
détecte chez vous que dans
45 jours, vous allez devenir violent.
Est-ce que vous avez vu le film Minority
Report ?
Non. C'est la science-fiction. Oui.
Est-ce que Est-ce que est-ce que on
pourra faire une justice par précrime ?
C'estàd que on va anticiper votre déjà,
il faudrait que la justice déjà soit en
temps réel.
[rires]
Commençons par là, après on verra.
Est-ce que la big data ça vous fait peur
? Dire que vous êtes vous êtes
[raclement de gorge] un un juge, vous
êtes carrément un artisan. Oui, bien
sûr.
Quand on voit de la big data à gogo,
vous faites juger, vous faites virer
d'une entreprise parce que il y a de
l'intelligence artificielle qui a été
approvisionnée avec des pipes de data.
Oui, mais attendez, il y a l'accès à
l'information.
Euh euh vous avez droit à la protection
de votre vie privée. On peut pas
utiliser les choses comme ça à votre
rencontre. On peut pas les fouiller dans
votre téléphone. On peut pas. Sauf si
vous avez déjà commis l'infraction. Mais
comme ça, a priori, on peut pas le faire
et heureusement.
Bon, vous êtes vieux mais toujours bien
vert, on a l'impression.
C'est vrai que je commence à être vieux.
Vous avez raison de me le [rires]
rappeler.
Combien combien il faut pour vous
engager dans le privé ? Si si nous on
décide de vous engager,
vous m'engagerez pas, ça m'intéresse
pas.
Admettons,
admettons.
On vous engage pour aller bosser. H
pour continuer votre boulot pour si si
j'ai envie d'avoir
Rena Vandunbec détective privé.
J'ai toujours travaillé pour le service
public,
je vais pas aller dans le privé
détective privé et puis bon vous l'avez
rappelé, je commence à avoir un certain
âge. Donc place aux jeunes. Je pense que
les jeunes aujourd'hui sont capables de
faire ce que moi j'ai pas pu faire.
C'està-dire qu'aujourd'hui par exemple
vous parliez d'internet tout ça, il y a
beaucoup d'information. Il y a beaucoup
de jeunes qui savent très bien s'en
servir beaucoup mieux que les gens de ma
génération. Moi, j'ai ma génération,
on on est on a fait la transition.
Voilà, on a montré qu'on pouvait, ça a
été dur, il a fallu payer de sa
personne, on pouvait remonter un certain
nombre d'affaires financières.
Maintenant
qui je passe le relais et moi ça y est,
j'ai je vais sucrer les fraises
maintenant.
du monoring
déjà les cultivés et j'en ai ramassé
l'autre jour, j'étais très content.
Vous habitez en Bretagne ?
Oui.
De la chance, il y a du
Je me suis lancé dans la permaculture.
Ah oui
oui.
Vous cultivez en but ?
Oui. Ah mais vous connaissez ?
Ah bah on a plein de copains qui
travaillent dans la permaculture.
Ah bah vous me donnerez des conseils en
sortant.
J'ai mis du bois au fond, du vieux bois
et cetera. Enfin comm à faire votre
diversion là. Si si, j'aime bien moi.
[rires]
Ah, vous avez mis le temps quand même.
Dans dans
votre dans votre bureau, quelle a été la
situation la plus surréaliste que vous
ayez amené à voir ?
Vous aviez l'impression d'être dans une
réalité euh parallèle tellement que
c'était surréaliste.
J'ai pas vraiment eu ce sentiment là,
voyez. J'ai plutôt eu le sentiment
d'aller dans le réalisme cru.
C'est-à-dire que derrière des
apparences, je allais dans le
[grognement] dans le dans le réel.
Non, j'ai pas bien répondre à votre
question, je le sens.
Non, non, mais il y a pas de il y a pas
de bonne ou une mauvaise réponse, hein.
Qu'est-ce que
On n'est pas sur une autre planète he
dans un bureau d'instruction, on
instruit, on pose des questions aux
gens, on fouille leur passé, on
[grognement] regarde ce qu'ils ont pu
faire, qui ce qu'ils mentent, ils
mentent pas. On est dans dans une
épreuve de réalité. On est sur du réel.
On est sur des choses vécues et
humainement. C'est c'est extrêmement
difficile parce que le le rôle du juge
consiste aussi à écouter.
Il y a pas les gentils et les méchants.
Moi, je fonctionne pas comme ça de
fonction manikenne.
J'ai une personne en face de moi, je la
soupçonne. Oui, peut-être que bon
je vais pas je la juge pas. Je vous l'ai
dit tout à l'heure, je juge pas. Je veux
juste comprendre ce qui s'est passé et
si s'il y a eu un délit, s'il y a eu une
infraction, je veux faire en sorte
qu'elle puisse être jugé et c'est
d'autres qui vont juger.
Si je vous dis quelle indignité, ça vous
fait penser à quoi ?
des gens qui fraudent
à grande échelle
et qui viennent se faire soigner
gratuitement à l'hôpital.
Est-ce que vous avez envie
parce que d'autres payent des impôts.
Est-ce que vous avez envie qu'on aborde
un sujet ensemble ? Est-ce qu'il y a un
sujet qui vous tient à cœur ? Est-ce
qu'il y a un sujet
Non, vous les avez abordés,
vous êtes un excellent juge
d'instruction.
[rires]
Vous seriez pardon mais vous êtes jeune,
vous pouvez encore postuler ou on a on a
d'autres missions à remplir avant.
Vous avez N'ayez pas de mépris comme ça
pour les juges d'instruction.
J'ai aucun j'ai j'ai aucun mépris pour
les juges d'instruction. J'en ai
peut-être un peu plus pour les
procureurs.
Il y a les procureurs très bien.
Oui. Beaucoup changé. Je parle de ses
affaires financières.
Comment il s'appelle votre bouquin déjà
?
mémoire d'un juge trop indépendant.
Pourquoi on a dit pourquoi vous avez
titré trop indépendant ? C'est la
perception des gens d'en face.
Non, c'est la c'est la perception de ma
hiérarchie pendant mes 10 premières
années d'exercice.
On m'a dit on m'a dit ça
dans des termes d'ailleurs très bien
tournés et je l'ai découvert que bien
plus tard quand j'ai été poursuivi
moi-même devant le Conseil supérieur de
la magistrature
dans l'affaire Clearstream. été
poursuivi
et pendant 6 ans
parce que vous êtes fait intoxiquer par
Jergin.
Oui, mais on avait juste oublié une
chose, c'est que c'est moi qui avait
prouvé que c'était faux.
Et oui, j'étais intoxiqué dans la
première approche, mais j'ai tout tout
de suite vérifié
et j'ai permis d'ailleurs aux personnes
qui étaient dans les fichiers de se de
déposer plainte puisque j'apporté la la
j'apporté la preuve que ces fichiers
étaient faux et j'étais finalement
blanchi par le CSM et j'étais poursuivi
pendant 6 ans et j'ai découvert à à ce
moment-là cette notation qu'on m'avait
mise quand j'étais jeune l'air de dire
on vous l'avait
Et vous aviez le nom de du gens qui a
fait la notation ?
Oui, c'est procureur général de l'époque
et puis le le président le premier
président de l'époque quand j'étais à
camp dans mes 10 premières années.
Alors,
c'est un clin d'œil ce titre
mais qui dit bien ce que ça veut dire.
Une phrase, on la prononcera pas ici.
Parlons du sentiment d'impunité.
Est-ce que vous avez eu dans votre
bureau des gens qui se sentaient
au-dessus des loises ? Bien sûr, pour
Oui, jusqu'à ce qu'ils arrivent dans mon
bureau.
Ben, il fait quelle tête ?
Je peux pas évoquer des dossiers
particuliers.
Pas mal. On va passer, on va prendre une
question internet.
Alors attention, on va la prendre à la
voler.
On va essayer de poser des questions
sympas les gars.
Ah bien. Doit-on accorder le droit
d'asile à Julien Assange ?
Comment ?
Doit-on accorder le droit d'asile à
Julien Assange ?
Je alors je vais vous dire franchement
ce que je pense pour Assange, c'est que
il a déjà payé largement payé. Je
comprends pas la position britannique
qui consiste à dire à le maintenir en
prison au bout de x années. Il a été il
a il a payé. Alors la question la
question fondamentale c'est de savoir si
dans les documents
qu'il a publié il a mis en péril la vie
de de personne. Voilà c'est c'est ça qui
me gêne. Maintenant je trouve qu'il y a
une forme d'açon
générale il faut des lanceurs d'alerte.
C'est triste à dire mais il y a que les
lanceurs d'alerte qui nous alertent.
Voilà. Mais euh les je pense que les
médias ne peuvent pas s'ils obtiennent
des informations euh très confidentielle
dans les services et cetera, leur
responsabilité c'est aussi de ne pas
mettre en péril l'avis de personne. Al
maintenant je je sais pas quel document
il a publié. J'ai pas étudié ce dossier.
J'en sais pas plus que vous mais je
pense quand même qu'il évitait un
acharnement. Oui.
Quand vous étiez en fonction, est-ce que
vous aviez des procédures spécifique
concernant
vos échanges personnels ? Est-ce que
vous chiffriez vos mails ? Est-ce que
j'aurais été incapable de le faire ?
Est-ce
que
je suis pas un bon informaticien ?
Ouais. Est-ce que vous échangiez par des
par mail ?
Par mail tout ouvert ?
Ouais.
Avec une messagerie
pas très professionnel.
Ouais. Non. avec une messagerie
atlaposte.fr ou atgoogle.fr.
Messagerie justice.
Ah oui, hébergé par [rires]
hébergé par nos copains.
Le le Revenons sur l'impunité.
Est-ce qu'en face de vous, il y a vous
aviez des gens qui étaient complètement
mégalot
se disant "J'ai des centaines de
millions sur mon compte, on va le
graisser un peu ?" ou
il le disait pas.
On a essayé on a essayé de vous graisser
un peu.
Non, ça ont jamais essayé.
Jamais.
Non, vous savez, on essaie de graisser
ce dont on pense qu'ils peuvent accepter
d'être graissés.
Ça peut aussi avoir un effet boomerang.
Il suffit d'acter. Ah bah tel m'a
proposé de l'argent et de le donner au
parquet. Bon,
est-ce que vous aviez des cas ? C'est
est-ce que c'est c'est je vais réussir à
saisir ma question, excusez-moi.
Est-ce qu'en face de vous sur les les la
délits d'école blanc
est-ce que c'est pas des capsis ? Est-ce
que c'est pas des gars qui mériteraient
d'aller en HP parce qu'ils sont
complètement mégalop ? Pas du tout.
Ils sont Non,
non, pas du tout. C'est les gens qui
savent raisonner et qui veulent gagner
plus d'argent. Non mais il y a des gens
très intelligents dans les hôpitaux
psychiatriques, hein.
Oui. Euh enfin moi, j'ai pas rencontré
de ce délinquant euh relevant la
psychiatrie.
Vraiment,
c'est pas c'est pas une pathologie.
Est-ce qu'il y en a qui ont essayé de
plaider la pathologie ?
Non.
l'innocence
toujours.
Oui. Euh monsieur par exemple vous avez
un million d'euros sur un compte
Lichtenstein.
C'est Mami.
Non,
c'est à votre nom. Mami a fait les
choses.
Ah et ben une fois j'ai eu la réponse.
Ah bah vous me la prenez.
[rires]
Ah vous me la prenez. Véridique
véridique
al moi j'aimerais bien qu'on m'apprenne
que c'est un million sans le savoirstein
saurait pas quoi en faire d'ailleurs.
Est-ce que vous avez auditionné des des
directeurs de grande banque ?
Oui, ça m'est arrivé.
Ça ressemble à quoi ?
Qu'est-ce que je voulais vous dise ? Il
y a
comme personne poursuivie voulait dire
ou comme ça peut être des témoins, ça
peut être des banques victime, ça peut
être
les banques qui savaient pas ça.
On prend une anecdote, une anecdote.
J'ai pas de d'anecdote en tête.
Alors, le temps de réfléchir, je pose
une autre question.
Est-ce que ça pose un problème quand
c'est le président qui choisit le
bâtonnier ?
qui choisit le juge. Je voulais dire
le juge, pardon.
Il faut bien qu'il y a une autorité qui
choisisse le juge.
Le président, c'est un magistrat
qui a qui a qui a un degré important et
qui est indépendant. Donc euh si vous
lui envlez ce pouvoir, à qui vous allez
le donner ? Mais c'est vrai que le choix
du juge est une question importante et
il faut s'assurer de la l'objectivité du
choix.
Et ben oui.
Je peux vous poser une autre question ?
Oui.
Je me demande ce qu'il pense de la loi
de moralisation de la vie publique de
Macron à son début de mandat. Question
de Elcorto.
Est-ce qu'on a besoin de faire une loi
pour moraliser la vie politique publique
? Je me souviens plus du contenu exact
de cette loi. Si vous pouvez me
rafraîchir la mémoire.
B qu' a des lois qui moralisent la vie
publique.
C'est pas choquant. En soit, c'est pas
choquant du tout. Au contraire, c'est
c'est les déclarations de patrimoine,
tout ça, je suppose. C'est Oui. Bah euh
mais attendez euh
si j'ai 5 millions de détournés euh
à Dubaï,
vous pensez que je vais le déclarer sur
toute ma sur mes déclarations de
patrimoine ?
Vous la prenez.
Donc on est encore dans le cas de figure
où on contrôle, on on met des contrôles
en France et cetera, mais le problème il
est ailleurs. On est le vrai problème,
il est là-bas. Euh
celui qui a des avoirs à l'étranger, il
les déclara jamais puisque par
définition c'est fraudé. Il va pas se
jeter la gueule dans la gueule du loup.
Question internet. Quel a été le plus
gros progrès de votre carrière ?
de ne pas avoir solution
d'avoir rencontré monsieur Gorin.
C'estàd que je n'ai pas
Oui.
Oui. Euh
vous savez, il avait paraît qu'il avait
hésité avec un autre juge.
Et votre plus gros regret, c'est qu'il
ait pas que contacter l'autre.
Oui. Voilà. Parce que on peut me
reprocher euh de l'avoir rencontré.
Enfin, dans l'affaire où j'étais, je
pouvais pas passer à côté d'une d'un
renseignement comme celui-là.
Simplement, j'ai quand même eu la
précaution de le vérifier. J'ai prouvé
que c'était faux. Bon, mais ça m'a valu
6 ans de poursuite. Franchement, si
j'étais s aurait pu ce jour-là ne pas le
croiser ou s'il était allé chez l'autre
juge, voilà, c'est mon regret. Premier
regret, c'est celui-là. J'ai quand même
passé 6 ans à devoir rendre des comptes
au Conseil supérieur de la magistrature.
6 ans alors que dès le premier jour, je
vous blanchi.
Oui, mais pendant 6 ans, j'ai compris ce
que c'était que d'être poursuivi par la
justice.
De l'autre côté de la barre. Voyez ce
que je veux dire ?
Question internet. Est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu peur
physiquement ?
Je me souviens qu'après la mort de
Robert Boulin,
j'avais reçu un message, une petite
lettre
anonyme bien sûr. Euh on faisait partie
du même comité de résistance que Robert
Moulin tuoublieras pas.
J'avais 27 ans. Avait toute la presse
qui venait de me tomber dessus. Euh c
être accusatrice de Robert Boula à mon
égard. Là, j'ai eu peur. Ouais. Je me
suis barricadé chez moi. J'ai vécu caché
parce que j'avais pas de protection à
l'époque du tout. Ça se faisait pas.
Et je me suis dit pourvu qu'il passe pas
qu'il passe pas aux actes
et puis il s'est rien passé. J'ai eu
peur pour rien.
Question internet. L'intelligence
économique versus droit entre
parenthèses politique fiscale pénale
liberté fondamentale. Fermez la
parenthèse l'œuf ou la poule.
F ou pool, c'est-à-dire que
l'intelligence économique, je je
comprends pas la question.
Voyez que j'ai une intelligence limitée.
Non non, on la comprend pas non plus.
Donc
Ah bah votre intelligence est limitée
comme la miel, ça me rassure.
On peut pas être omniprésent ni potent,
c'est impossible.
[rires]
On n'est pas juge d'instruction.
Non, j'ai pas compris la question.
Écoutez-moi non plus. Donc on va lui
demander de la de la repréciser un peu
plus bas. Question internet. La justice
devrait-elle être plus indépendante
garde des sauts séparés du pouvoir
politique pour l'interrogation ?
Non, je pense qu'il faut séparer les
parcs. Elles devraient être plus
indépendantes. C'est une des
propositions que je fais dans mon dans
mon livre, hein. C'est que les parquets
soient totalement indépendants, qu'on
coupe le cordon entre le pouvoir
politique et les procureurs.
Oui, ça je le pense.
Vous voulez rajouter un mot ?
Non, c'est c'est clair. Je crois que je
l' entendu.
Que pense Question Internet. Que
pensent-il de l'État assigné en justice
pour l'inaction face au dérèglement
climatique ? Entre parenthèse, encore
séparation des pouvoirs. Quel moyen pour
forcer l'État à agir ?
Ben, vous savez, en France, on se
retourne toujours vers l'État.
Euh moi, je pense que
il faudrait une évaluation carbone par
personne. Voyez, j'aimerais bien que ça
soit fait ça parce que ça veut dire bah
je prends plus l'avion, je prends plus
ma voiture. Je pense qu'il y a une masse
de comportement dont on bénéficie tous.
Donc dire c'est la faute à l'État, vous
savez, c'est la faute à Voltaire, c'est
la faute à l'État, on peut mais ça va
pas résoudre le problème parce que si on
condamne l'État, c'est ceux qui payent
des impôts qui vont payer. Enfin bon,
faut arrêter à un moment donné. Donc
moi, je crois beaucoup au comportement
individuel déjà et puis qui une volonté
politique évidemment de
de transformer tout ça. Après, c'est une
question politique.
Je complète cette question et la plainte
contre 5 ministres directement.
sur la la question climatique
laissons faire la justice.
Question internet
de une question de Yanou selon lui
pourquoi il y a aujourd'hui moins de
grands juges tels que lui ou madame Eva
Jolie moins d'affaires ou moins de juges
entre guillemets couillus ?
Alors, je pense simplement euh je laisse
la responsabilité de des propos à celui
qui les présente comme ça. Je pense
simplement qu'aujourd'hui il y a euh
moins de moins de fixation sur tel ou
tel juge, moins de médiatisation parce
que dans les grandes affaires, les juges
sont désignés à plusieurs.
C'est plus anonymisé. C'estàd que alors
la presse toujours focalise parfois sur
un des juges mais il y a il y a des
collégialités, il y a des codésignations
aujourd'hui qui font en sorte que il y a
moins de médiatisation autour de la
personne d'un juge. Quand ce sont trois
juges qui agissent, c'est difficile de
médiatiser quand il y en a qu'un.
Évidemment.
Question d'internet. Quite de l'avenir
du droit français à l'heure de la
mondialisation et des droits et des
droits étrangers qui finissent pour par
s'imposer entre parenthèses les USA.
Est-ce que le droit français, il va être
condamné à périqulité face au droits
américains ?
Non, je crois pas.
Non. Chaque pays a le droit, c'est le
produit d'une culture. On a chacun
chacun notre culture. Simplement, il y a
peut-être des valeurs universelles
qu'on sert tous quelque part, en tout
cas dans les démocraties.
Quel est le plus gros montant des
tournées que vous ayez amené à passer
devant vos yeux et sous votre nez ?
100 millions.
Alors après, il y a il y a des dossiers,
on parlait des dossiers des Friad de
Taiwan, c'est 500 millions. Bon,
s'apportait sur des à l'époque alors on
était en franc j'aurais du mal à
convertir, mais des centaines de
millions, des centaines de millions
d'euros, voilà, les plus gros les plus
gros cas.
Question internet. Ça donne quoi le
profil du type des escrous col blancs ?
C'est quoi leur profil type ?
Il y a pas de profil type.
Question internet. A-t-il été frustré à
l'époque par le verou de Bercy ?
Non, j'ai pas été frustré et je peux pas
l'être parce que euh le juge
d'instruction, il est saisi de certaines
affaires par le procureur. Il est pas
saisi par le par Mercy. Merci saisit le
procureur, ensuite le juge
d'instruction. Donc euh le le la
frustration n'est pas là. La frustration
c'est lorsque vous instruisez un
dossier, vous découvrez des faits
nouveaux et vous pouvez pas continuer.
Ça oui, mais le juge n'est pas ne se
saisit pas de ces dossiers. il a
instruit les dossiers qu'on lui donne.
Il va pas dire tiens, je voudrais bien
avoir tel dossier ou tel autre dossier,
tel dossier m'échappe pour telle ou
telle raison. Donc directement non, j'ai
pas été frustré.
Question internet.
Est-ce que son manque de zel concernant
le volet financier des sous-marins de
Karachi s'explique par le coût de
pression subi peu de temps avant pendant
l'affaire Clearstream ?
Pourquoi manque de ailes dans l'affaire
Karachi ?
Totalement infondé. Totalement infondé.
uns que j'ai instruit,
il a été renvoyé devant le tribunal.
Euh, il y a des personnes, c'est en
cours de jugement, c'est en cours
d'appel. Je vois pas,
j'ai rien. Alors, je vais vous dire une
chose. Euh je n'ai jamais étouffé un
dossier de ma vie. Enfin, c'est
contraire à tout ce que à tout ce que à
toutes mes conceptions, à tout ce que
j'ai pu faire. Donc là, je je comprends
pas la question.
Un avis sur Denis Robert ? Oui.
Bah
Robert, je l'ai connu au moment de
l'appel de Genève. Euh il a eu à une
époque un rôle important dans cet appel
qui alors je rappelle pour ceux qui
savent pas ce que c'est, c'est une
réunion de quelques juges européens à
Genève qui ont dénoncé justement les
paradis fiscaux en 96. Voilà. Denis
Robert a été à l'initiative de cette de
cette démarche. Après Denis Robert,
c'est un journaliste, il s'est retrouvé
dans un combat personnel et difficile
avec Clearstream. Bon,
est-ce que vous avez un commentaire sur
le travail d'anticorps ?
Non, Anticorp c'est une association qui
lutte contre la corruption. quand ils
est que le que le parquet n'agit pas,
que le procureur n'agit pas, ils ont la
possibilité de se constituer partie
civile. C'est comme une soupape, si vous
voulez de de saisir directement les
juges d'instruction quand ils estiment
que des faits de cette nature, des
infractions financières sont commises.
Qu'est-ce que vous pensez des
cryptomonnaies ?
Bah, je sais pas quoi en penser.
Question internet. Est-ce que vous avez
pas étouffé le dossier Carviel ?
Pas du tout.
pas du tout. J'ai instruit le dossier
Carviel. D'ailleurs, j'ai développé tout
un chapitre dans mon livre sur l'affaire
Carviel.
J'ai instruit ce dossier avec une
collègue d'ailleurs pendant 18 mois.
J'ai étudié les deux thèses.
Voilà. Après, je je peux pas porter de
jugement comme ça sur une affaire qui
que j'ai instruite, mais je n'ai eu que
de mon seul objectif c'est de rechercher
la vérité qui n'était pas forcément
celle que certains voulaient entendre.
Voilà. et j'ai étudié les deux thèses,
j'ai vérifié, je me suis basé sur des
documents que j'avais pu saisir et je
suis moi-même allé à la banque pour pas
pour puisque tout était contesté pour
m'assurer que j'ai étudié les emails. Ça
a été compliqué parce que euh les fors,
j'y connaissais absolument rien. Mais
bon, je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
comment
c'est pour ça qu'on vous a mis sur le
dossier.
Bah je crois que aucun juge ni savait ce
que c'était qu'un for et un futur. Donc
il y avait pas de concurrence à ce
niveau-là. Je crois que non. Euh j'ai
étudié, je me suis plongé sur la
question et puis j'ai surtout étudié
tous les emails qui avait été euh
échangé au moment des contrôles pendant
toute la phase, pendant les 18 mois.
Voilà. Et je me suis basé sur des sur
des éléments
que je suis allé chercher en m'assurant
qu'ils étaient authentiques. Et à partir
de là, j'en ai tiré des conclusions.
J'ai renvoyé le dossier devant le
tribunal. Donc je vois pas ce que
j'aurais pu étouffer. J'ai renvoyé
devant le tribunal, il y a eu débat
public, il a été condamné, recondamné en
cours d'appel, en cassation. Donc
voilà. Après, moi j'assume tout à fait
ce que j'ai fait, mais j'ai rien étouffé
du tout. Au contraire, j'ai essayé je me
suis efforcé de clarifier une affaire
qui paraissait pas évidente du tout,
quelle que soit la tess qu'on a qu'on a
dès le départ. Mais justement, oui.
Comment vous avez saisi les mails ? Je
suis allé à la banque.
Les mails, vous avez dit vous me donnez
vos mails.
Oui, mais déjà au départ on avait des
mails. Il y avait il y avait des
documents qui ont été communiqué par qui
?
Par la banque.
Euh et ensuite, je suis allé vérifier un
certain nombre de points qui étaient
contestés en allant directement à la
banque. Bon,
comment on fait au 21e siècle quand il y
a des messageries chiffrées,
il y a des boîtes noires à gauche à
droite ? Alors, on a des experts, on a
des policiers spécialisés qui savent qui
savent décrypter ce genre de choses.
Donc ça prend du temps, c'est compliqué
mais
voilà. Mais vous imaginez, attendez,
vous imaginez une seconde une banque
comme la cité générale fabriquée à
postérier des faux mailes. Vous imaginez
ça ? Les produire à la justice ?
Non mais sérieusement,
question, c'est une question.
Oui,
j'imagine pas, je suis pas là pour
imaginer.
Bon ben voilà, c'est tout. Euh mais j'ai
quand même été vérifié parce que mon
métier c'est de vérifier
parce que vous êtes pas payé pour
imaginer.
Non, au contraire.
Vous auriez fait un bon juge
d'instruction hein
peut-être, je sais pas. [rires]
Donc pas de commentaire sur les
cryptoonnaies. Le Bitcoin, non,
moi je me méfie a priori mais bon,
il y a deux écoles. Je je j'en sais pas
plus. J'ai jamais alors j'ai jamais eu
de dossier là-dessus. Non, j'en sais
rien. J'en sais pas plus que vous.
Est-ce que vous avez trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
De conseiller à qui ?
À notre communauté, aux gens qui nous
écoutent. Trois trois bouquins qui vous
ont marqué
nécessaire
dans le domaine dont on parle.
Droit aux partition de musique.
La vallée de Berman de liste.
Deux bouquins maintenant.
de bouquins.
Euh
le livre de l'intranquillité,
très grand très grand livre du du 20e
siècle.
Et puis pour ceux qui aiment la
permaculture, Mali Croix de Bosco, j'en
ai trois.
La bibliothèque qui a chez vous, c'est
une vraie ou une fausse ?
C'est une
C'est une vraie ou une fausse ?
Ah bah une vraie.
[rires]
Est-ce que vous avez un un conseil pour
les jeunes générations ? Une bouteille à
la mer, quelque chose qui va rester
impérissable sur les réseaux,
c'est-à-dire quelque chose que vous
laissez à vos petits enfants sur les
réseaux en vidéo, sur l'internet. Un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Comme conseil pour Mais soyez fidèles à
vos idéaux.
la jeunesse, ils ont des on a des idéaux
quand on est jeune. Ben faut être fidèle
toute sa vie, c'est tout. Et puis faites
ce que vous avez envie de faire.
Monsieur le juge Renaand Runec, merci.
C'est moi qui vous remercie de votre
patience.
Coup.
[musique]